but they know as much about this bill as
I do and much of half the Internet um
there used to be forty two hundred
thousand references to me and when you
google my name to week seven his book
came out there's about two million let's
this book is making a lot of noise
everywhere Irishman John Linder thank
you over the span of three decades
Pulitzer prize-winning historian Doris
Kearns Goodwin has written about such
political figures as Lyndon Johnson the
Kennedys and Roosevelt's in wait till
next year MS Goodwin looks back on her
childhood and her love of baseball and
reading her latest book is team of
rivals about President Lincoln's
leadership and his relationship with
three powerful members of his cabinet
next a three-hour discussion with author
and historian Doris Kearns Goodwin Doris
Kearns Goodwin at last count 1191 books
in print on Abraham Lincoln more than
John Kennedy Franklin Roosevelt and
Ronald Reagan combined why this latest I
knew I wanted to live with him and I
just had to have a leap of faith that I
could find something that would be my
own way into him but they take me so
long these books the last one on it
Eleanor and Franklin took six years
longer than World War two so I knew this
was going to be a big part of my life I
wanted to know about him I wanted to
know about the Civil War and he turned
out to be the best companion I could
have imagined how did you begin the
process well at first I just read you
know I was just reading and reading and
reading and I hoped at the beginning to
do a book about Abe and Mary the way I
had done with Eleanor and Franklin but I
realized that she couldn't hold the
public side of the story Mary couldn't
the way Eleanor did and as I started
reading more and more I realized that he
was spending even more time with the
members of his cabinet who would chase
and stanton than with Mary he was almost
married to them more in such a tense
time they wait for news from the
battlefield they go to the front they
relax together at night so I thought
these are the guys I'm interested and
then when it turned out they had been
his rivals beforehand I finally realized
I've got my story now there's a book
that came out more than 60 years ago by
Burton Hendrick on Lincoln's war back
without different from that book and
this one well what he did was not so
much primary so
he used secondary sources and though
there was a lot of good stuff in them
he's a very good writer but he had one
huge chapter on chase while huge chapter
on Seward one huge chapter on Stanton
mine is really a narrative and goes back
to intertwining them all from the
beginning to the end you've written a
number of books that included primary
sources you're now dealing with 19th
century figures as opposed to 20th
century figures so how do you go about
the research process well I was worried
at first because I'd been so lucky even
in the Roosevelt time there were three
dozen people who knew him who knew the
family and of course with Lyndon Johnson
I was able to spend hours at a time
talking with that giant of a man so I
thought how am I going to go back to a
period where I can't talk to anyone but
it turns out because they kept Diaries
and because they wrote letters in that
period of time it's an even more
intimate source than anything we'll have
today historians 200 years from now
we'll never know as much about us I
think as we're able to know about these
characters in the nineteenth century
even Seward's family his secretary of
state 5,000 letters they wrote between
them so I love reading letters from you
feel like you're right over their
shoulders I want to read a couple of
excerpts from the book first of all you
say that Abraham Lincoln William Henry
Seward salmon chase and Edward Bates
were members of a restless generation of
Americans destined to leave behind the
eighteenth-century world of their
fathers thousands of miles separate
their birthplaces of Virginia New York
New Hampshire and Kentucky nonetheless
social and economic forces shaped with
shaped their path and also marked a
number of similarities how so well I
think what was so interesting for all
the members of that generation the
American experiment in democracy was
still new so here's this next generation
coming along politics is the passion of
the people so it's not surprising that
all these characters entered political
life you know when they would give a
talk or there'd be a debate 10,000
people might come and people would
listen to for our talks not what you
could imagine today they say that
politics back then was what sports are
for us today so that's what shaped all
of them they all wanted to become
lawyers so that they could become
politicians so they could participate in
the public life of our country because
that's where the passion was why did one
of these become a running mate Abraham
Lincoln
that's a great question I think partly
because once they got there and the
convention decided that it was Abraham
Lincoln then they're looking somehow for
balance and they probably knew that none
of these guys would be willing to accept
the vice presidency vice presidency
wasn't very powerful in those days so I
can imagine they would rather say no
we'll wait and we'll be him the next
time around let's go through each
individuals first of all who was William
Seward who was my favorite of the
characters he reminds me of Churchill he
could drink he could smoke he had
parties in his house in the 1850s where
there'd be so much wine that even
southerners would feel good about the
northerners and he was the one who
everybody thought would be the Menomonee
he had been the great anti-slavery order
in the 50s the most celebrated name so
many people came to his house waiting
for the news that he had been nominated
but champagne had already been uncorked
he was irrecoverably disappointed and
yet when Lincoln appointed him Secretary
of State he thought he would control
Lincoln and Lincoln would be a mere
figurehead but in the end he and Lincoln
became great friends once he realized
that Lincoln was who Lincoln was a very
special character and their friendship
was one of the most surprising parts of
this for me
salmon cheese salmon chase was a
different kind of character and Seward
because he didn't drink he didn't smoke
very religious he would practice jokes
that he could never quite deliver with
ease he kept a diary from the time he
was 20 years old and he was a very
self-righteous kind of character however
he had been great as an abolitionist so
he was an honor honorable person in the
problems for black equality he wanted to
be President so much that even when
Lincoln made him secretary of the
Treasury he still kept running against
Lincoln and tried to maneuver against
him and win the second time around but
Lincoln bested him in Judge Edward ates
baek's was an elder statesman from
Missouri and people thought maybe he
could be President because he was more
conservative and came from a border
state when he was a young man he was
very interested in politics like the
rest of them but then he got married to
this woman that he loved so much
that he couldn't bear being away from
her when he was on his way to Congress
he said why am i doing this I miss you
it's I have this indefinable Restless
feeling well he wasn't away from her
very long because they had 17 children
but it's interesting it shows how family
life can affect public life in the 19th
century when men wrote about history
they barely mentioned that you had a
wife or a family
but you can see in each one of these
cases even chase he had this beautiful
daughter he lost three young lives at 22
25 and 30 or something and his daughter
becomes his life and his campaign
manager and his partner marries a
wealthy older man just to further his
ambitious and then she dies in poverty
so I love these stories of the wives and
the husband's 17 children how many lived
to adulthood nine led to adulthood you
write about the man in your life in the
epilogue of the book and you say did you
dedicate this book to your husband I owe
more than I can ever Express to my
husband which a good one to whom this
book is dedicated he read and edited
every single page I argued with him what
did you argue about well sometimes we
would argue about whether Lincoln was
doing the right thing he's such a huge
Lincoln fan and we would decide if I
were trying to be critical of him and
he'd say what are you saying that's my
Lincoln and I'd say no this is wrong
with him this is right of him it was
fantastic he studied Lincoln all the
time we're both writers we work at home
he in one section of the house me in
another section and it was fantastic to
have somebody like that reading every
single I give pages every day as I
finished them and you go on you say you
debated about Lincoln and he thought is
deeply about Lincoln is anyone did he
inspire you to do this book or did you
come up with the idea of like in your
life I think I came up with the idea of
it but once I got into it and he started
reading about Lincoln as well you know
my husband was a speechwriter for John
Kennedy and for Lyndon Johnson and so he
understands the value of words in public
life so there's nobody that he felt more
comfortable with then Lincoln's
brilliance as a wordsmith and as a
speaker to the nation who came up with
the title oh the title was a problem for
a while we wanted to call it master
among men because that's really what
it's about his human relationships but
given that he was the great Emancipator
it seems like that might be a worrisome
word to use the title with the master in
it I always knew political genius of
Abraham Lincoln would be the subtitle
but for a while we were going to call it
the great unifier or American Colossus
and this had always been the working
title way from the beginning so we just
went back to what it had been as the
working title team of rivals which is
really what it's about our conversation
for the next three hours here on c-span
two's book TV in-depth Doris Kearns
Goodwin as always we welcome you phone
calls if you live in eastern and central
time zones the number to call is two
zero two seven three seven triple zero
one but
the UN a mountain or Pacific time zones
two zero two seven thirty seven zero
zero zero two and you can email us your
questions at book TV at c-span org in
your last conversation with Lyndon
Johnson you talked about Abraham Lincoln
interestingly he was reading Sandberg's
biography on Lincoln and trying to
conjure Lincoln to life and he couldn't
quite do it and he said if he couldn't
bring Lincoln to life in his mind no one
was going to remember him he was so
haunted in those last year's by weather
history would remember him you know I
now realize more than I did when I was
25 years old what a privilege it was to
have spent so many hours with this aging
lion of a man he had won so many
conquests had done so much in civil
rights and yet felt in the end as if his
career had been destroyed by the war in
Vietnam so I had those hours with him
and it was an extraordinary chance I
think it's what propelled me to want to
understand the inner person behind the
public figure that I've tried to bring
to all these books since then when was
this photograph taken
oh god this is when I was selected as a
White House Fellow that must have been
the days when women wore shin yawns that
false hair is in the back of my head
it's a very embarrassing photo but that
was at the celebration when the White
House fellows were announced and what
happened weirdly was that I did dance
with President Johnson when we were
selected but had been a graduate student
when I was selected at Harvard and like
many young people active in the
anti-vietnam war movement so I had
written an article against Johnson which
unfortunately came out after being
selected as a White House Fellow and the
theme of the article was how to get rid
of Lyndon Johnson in 1968 I was sure he
would kick me out of the program but
instead surprisingly he said oh bring
her down here for a year and if I can't
win her over no one can so I did end up
working for him and then helping him on
his memoirs
you mentioned the dancing in the book
Lyndon Johnson the American dream he
said he came up he said do you dance up
at Harbor and he said you said of course
they do bull he responded I know what
goes on up there and I bet they can't
dance like I'm dancing with you right
now absolutely let me twirled me around
the floor he's so big and he also had
this weird habit of standing closer to
human beings than normally people stand
separated so I felt like I was in his
chest half the time when I was talking
to him and when I danced he literally
picked me up from the floor going around
the room let's get
some phone calls for the North Koreans
good when first up is Oberlin Ohio good
morning
oh good morning I just purchased the
book two days ago I'm into the first 200
pages of it
huge fan of Lincoln my question is
Lincoln's ability to reach out to his
political rivals and incorporate them
into a larger scheme would you comment
on the seeming impossibility of that
happening now it's a great question I
think it would be much harder now I mean
because now we have this permanent
campaign so the minute a president is
elected he's already thinking of the
second term in Lincoln's day most
presidents for the previous presidents
had just had a single term so they're
not so obsessed about winning and today
I think they'd be worried about giving a
platform for their rival that they could
then use against them in the in the
following four years the other thing is
that these guys were all rivals of one
another not just of Lincoln
so they said terrible things about one
another you'll see as you get further in
the book unmitigated scoundrel Stanton
and Chase half the times weren't talking
to postmaster Blair they wouldn't go to
each other's offices can you imagine
what it would happen tonight if we were
to hear on the news these guys in the
cabinet saying these things about each
other it would explode the whole thing
unless you had a Lincoln to hold it
together
I wish it were possible though because
what it meant was that he had all the
different aspects of the Republican
Party moderates conservatives liberals
together in the same tent so it was
easier somehow to deal with them than it
would have been if they were outside
this morning in the Washington Post in
the review of the book they say it would
be comparable to George W Bush selecting
John McCain as defense secretary exactly
as his chief person knowing that he was
giving a platform the first time around
McCain to one second on but you know
what it might have been a great thing if
you have people who are going to oppose
you who are going to argue with you are
going to debate you inside your cabinet
then maybe you hone your skills and
you're able to deal with the country and
if you do well with the country don't
worry about the next election it'll
probably come to you
Kansas City Missouri you're next go
ahead please yes thank you very much for
taking my call I was wondering if
there's any historical documents about
how Lincoln dealt with some of the
savagery that happened as a byproduct of
the
Civil War from the southerners like the
quantrell's Raiders and things of that
nature that did a lot of butchery does
Lincoln do anything at all to try to
stop it or what was how was his feelings
about those kinds of rivalries it's a
very good question and I think it's one
of the things that was very hard for
Lincoln s so it should have been at some
point they decided in the north that the
only way the war could finally be one
was if indeed the southern capacity to
make war were destroyed which meant
destroying the railroads this is
Sherman's march to the sea in particular
destroying the crops and the continent
was being sold to make money in order to
keep the South in the war and I suspect
from what we see from the Lincoln's
conversations with people as much as he
knew that that was a terrible byproduct
of war he figured unless the southern
capacity to make war were destroyed it
would keep going on and on and on even
more people would die if he didn't do
that turn our attention to another
former president what role did you have
in writing this book or working on this
book with Lyndon Johnson the vantage
point well I was just one of a series of
people who helped him on his memoirs and
particularly worked on the civil rights
chapters and the chapter of his
relationship with Congress which is the
best part of Lyndon Johnson so I went
down to the ranch stayed with him at the
ranch sometimes stayed in Austin while I
was beginning to teach at Harvard and as
I say it was just to listen to him
recollect he was a great storyteller I
used to just listen for hours as he
would tell me stories not just about the
part of the vantage point but stories
about his childhood because he was
originally going to write a trilogy
starting with the presidency going back
to the Senate and then to his childhood
so a lot of our conversations would
range over his whole life I used to
tease that his stories were so
fantastically colorful even though half
of them weren't true I loved them
nonetheless it was my question how much
could you believe not a lot but I think
that's what he liked me there because I
like listening to his tall tales let me
read you what Rick Ralston wrote in
history News Network he said I wonder
how doris kearns who ghost wrote much of
Lyndon Johnson's 1971 memoirs the
vantage point felt upon its publication
to be listed in the preface as merely
one of a dozen of people who aided in
the preparation research writing and
editing of this book oh there's no way
that I go throughout it absolutely not
no in fact there were far more important
people working on that memoir than I was
and they spent more time they were doing
it
full-time I was just doing it part-time
and only worked on those two chapters
and all that meant was that he talked to
me and then you put down what he says
and try and get it in some form so no I
I thought that was more than enough you
know recommendation for what I had done
absolutely quote from Lyndon Johnson
after he took the oath of office he said
I became president but for millions of
Americans I was still illegitimate a
naked man with no presidential covering
a Pretender to the throne and then there
was Texas my home the home of both the
murderer and murdering Johnson always
spoke in somewhat graphic language you
can only imagine what it must have been
like for him to know that the country
had loved John Kennedy so much must have
wondered did he have something to do
with his assassination because it took
place in Texas and then the murder of
the murderer as he said what was amazing
was that even with all of that pressure
on him he achieved an extraordinary
transition and then the next year 1965
was one of the great years in American
history so he only hadn't gotten into
Vietnam I think he would have been
remembered as a great president next
call comes to us from Ann Arbor Michigan
on book TV go ahead please Doris Kearns
Goodwin it surely is you're my hero well
thank you so much I dropped out of
school professor and then I went back
and I started studying history I went
back to the Community College and the
more I learned about it the more I
really warmed up to it and what gets me
is how historians can look at something
and they can differ from their
interpretation if they're lucky
columnist you get them in a room and
they don't agree but I want to ask you
about how exactly do historians go about
gathering evidence and one thing that
always struck me about President Lincoln
this is just the layman's observation it
seems like he had the ability to look
outside of himself and to see how other
people saw him and I always kind of
wanted about that and then lastly what
about these charges of this that you
hear news about like Stephen Ambrose
like plagiarism and stuff like that now
hang up and god bless you and thank you
thank you so much well I think just
answer your
in question I think you're absolutely
right that his ability to look at
himself from the outside in its it's
stretched I think from this enormous
confidence that he had inside himself
and also a remarkable sense of humor I
think anyone who's funny and has a sense
of humor part of it is the ability to
laugh at oneself and I think that was a
great great quality in him what happens
when historians write history is that we
go back and we look at as many primary
sources as we can which means using the
Diaries using the letters using oral
histories and then you try to figure out
from yourself you're going to read
different conflicting ideas of what
somebody did you just have to
intuitively understand you know your guy
how do I think he responded how do I
think he didn't respond and in terms of
your last question it's a complicated
process putting together a huge book
like this or any of our books as was
true for Steven Ambrose as well there's
usually thousands of footnotes lots of
different sources and sometimes what can
happen has happened to me as well is
that even though I had given absolute
credit to the person from whom I had
taken some some passages and not put the
correct folks quote marks in the right
place I'd credited her once I found out
about it I myself said that she was
right I corrected it in the next edition
and then moved on but it's part of the
process which is a complicated one of
doing a huge historical work but it's
worth every cent to be able to put all
those sources together and give a
narrative hopefully to the reader that
can make the people come alive for you
personally what was the biggest lesson
after the revelation came out from this
book to Fitzgerald's and the Kennedys I
think the biggest lesson was that you
acknowledge the era I mean I
acknowledged it at the time I corrected
it to the author's satisfaction when it
became public again three years ago I
acknowledged it again there's nothing
you can do to change the past other than
to make sure that like for example in
this Lincoln book everything is checked
and everything is fine that's what can
you do other than do that there are a
hundred pages a hundred plus pages of
footnotes and bibliography well I think
the reason for that would have been true
even if this hadn't happened because
there's so many primary sources and
there's something about the Lincoln
world they're a very generous group of
scholars that people who studied Lincoln
all their lives
so when you found new things you want to
put in the footnote for those other
scholars sources that they can look
after themselves so it's really a
sense a sharing process and all those
notes I think the Lincoln scholars will
be happy and hopefully 100 years from
now some young scholar will say yes I
found a source because it was there you
wrote in an essay to Time magazine after
it was revealed in January 2002 that it
also taught you about your own
salability absolutely I mean you know
there's no way that you can be perfect
and anything I would like to believe
that in most of my books what I've been
able to do is to deal fairly with the
characters to never have a bias toward
them not to be mean toward them but you
also want to make sure that you've
credited every source everything fully
and appropriately done and so you learn
about that and you make sure to do it
right me ask you about the Fitzgeralds
in the counties because it was delayed
by about two years because of some new
documents that you found what were they
Oh what happened was that it turned out
that Teddy Kennedy gave me access to 150
cartons that had been the attic and
Hyannisport for over 50 years and it
turned out that Joe and Rose Kennedy had
saved almost everything every letter
that they wrote to one another check
stubs movie cards letters from the
family and it was really a way into the
Kennedy family that I wouldn't have had
without those so it was worth spending
another couple years I mean that book
took me almost 10 years to I'm not too
fast on these things and you write in
the book that had times been different
Eunice
could have been the politician in the
family there's no question about that I
mean she was the one it's interesting
there were three kids at the top of the
family Joe jr. Jack and Kathleen and
they were considered like the golden
trio everything right for them and of
course there was the [ __ ] daughter
rosemary and then came Eunice and Eunice
was sort of like the person who took
care of everybody else in the family and
the closest one to rosemary she had
intensity she had Drive and in some ways
I think she was the leader of that
younger group of generations of the
Kennedys and they often said if she had
been a boy she would have been the one
who ran for office in 1946 much more
outgoing than was Jack Kennedy but it
wasn't that time and age but she's done
remarkable things with the Special
Olympics and with her commitment to
mental retardation as a result what did
you learn about Kathleen who died in the
plane crash in 1947 well she was the
rebel in the family in a certain sense I
mean she went over to Europe with her
father she fell in love with the Duke of
Harding to Duke Hartington the Duke of
Devonshire Billy Hartington and
she married him even though he was
Protestant and then fell in love yet
again with another Protestant after he
died in the war she was beautiful she
was feisty and I think had her own life
apart from the Kennedys more than most
of the other family members did in the
book and I'm trying to find a quote but
you you'll probably say better than then
I can say it you write about how Joe
senior came down and told his family on
the death of Joe junior it was a blow I
think for Joe senior that was never to
be restored I think he was forever
altered by that Joe junior was the one
that they thought would be the President
of the United States much more socially
at ease than Jack was when he was
younger more handsome if you can
possibly imagine that and all the
family's hopes were put on him when Joe
senior found out that he'd been killed
in a plane crash in World War two I
don't think he I don't think people
thought he would survive Rose had her
faith she had her love with God
she knew that somehow Joe junior was
with God and she would be with him
someday but Joe senior said he wasn't so
sure about that and he didn't know
whether he could take take this thing it
was like it was like a break that would
never be restored in the family what did
the Kennedy family members tell you
about that afternoon well I think what
Rose said was I mean somebody came to
the door to tell them and and there was
a sense of not wanting to believe it
which must be true I guess for anybody
who hears about a son or daughter being
killed in the military but you know the
minute that somebody comes in what
they're about to tell you and they just
they finally separate it and try to make
the best of it and then what happened
that helped rose a little bit a lot of
Joe juniors friends and colleagues and
people who'd been in the military with
him wrote letters to her and told her
what a wonderful leader he was and how
great he was so that gave a certain
solace I suspect next call comes to us
from Phoenix go ahead please yep through
my nervousness I'm going to ask two or
three quick questions and then a hang up
and listen don't be nervous we'll take
it one at a time okay number one you
said you try to write these books and by
the way even though you were accused of
some things every time you are on I
watch you thank you so nice and I think
that you given a credit to President
Johnson everybody thinks Kennedy did all
of these things to help the poor in them
on our
but it was actually President Johnson
and he doesn't get the credit but he's
going back to Lincoln I don't understand
you said you try to write these
biographies without biases Lincoln raped
and tortured the United States
Constitution more than any other
president in the history of man
habeas corpus locking up newspaper
writers jailing people who spoke out
against him I'm talking about people in
the north not in the south I hadn't read
your book did you include that did you
include the fact that he violated the
United States Constitution that he
should have been I mean under I mean if
George Bush did that now you know people
would be calling for impeachment abraham
lincoln central I wanted to centralize
the United States government personally
I think slavery was I'm a Christian I
believe it was an abomination I think
it's the worst in this country has ever
committed against itself but I believe
slavery could have been reconciled
through the North paying the South but
rather than that and a lot of people
don't realize it when they sent the ship
before Fort Sumter it wasn't to say you
can't have slaves it was to say we're
going to quintuple the amount of taxes
that you're paying on cotton and that's
when the shots were fired
Lincoln violated the Constitution like
no other president ever has before him
or after him and that to me that's one
of the most important legacies of his
administration that would you know it's
terrible when anybody is killed but I
could understand how somebody like John
Wilkes Booth who supposedly was from a
good family and a very intelligent man
and and you know had good connections
would say you know this guy has
destroyed the Constitution thank you let
me let me talk to a series of those
things that you've said what Lincoln
thought he was preserving and what he
was preserving was not simply the Union
it wasn't simply even emancipating the
slaves he believed that if the South
were allowed to secede
the whole experiment that was democracy
would be destroyed the South would
secede slavery would stay in the South
and then maybe the West would secede
from the East and everyone in the world
would be delighted that this beacon of
hope that America represented that
ordinary people could govern themselves
would be undone so it was something very
large that he was fighting for there's
no question that in wartime civil
liberties suffer there's no question
that when he undid habeas corpus he had
his reasons for doing it what happened
is that the troops were coming to
protect Washington people in Maryland
were preventing them from getting there
so he needed to do something he thought
to get the troops there or the whole
cause would be lost but nonetheless
that's not an excuse and more time it's
somebody said Justice Marshall said even
in times of the most merchant urgency is
when you need to be most protective of
the Constitution but without that Civil
War slavery would have continued but
more important than that people thought
at least until the 20th century it would
have continued and it was as you say an
abomination but even more as I say if
the South had been allowed to secede
that everything we stood for in the
world and still stand for would have
been undone lots of people had to die
it's a terrible thing they had to die
wartime is a mess war is hell as
somebody said but I think most
historians would argue that that was one
of those wars that had to be fought as
sad as it was page 735 the chapter the
final weeks you write just as Brutus had
been honored for the slaying of the
tyrant Julius Caesar John Wilkes Booth
believed he would be exalted for killing
an even greater tyrant assassinating
Lincoln would not be enough Booth knew
his biographer observes that in the end
the Brutus conspiracy was foiled by Mark
Antony who's famous oration made outlaws
of the assassins and a martyr of Caesar
and then to paraphrase William Henry
Seward was Lincoln's Mark Antony right I
mean what I hadn't fully absorbed until
I got deeply into this was that John
Wilkes Booth had a triple assassination
plot it wasn't going to be enough to
kill Lincoln because he wanted to
decapitate the entire structure of
northern leadership so we had a
co-conspirator that was going to
assassinate Andrew Johnson the vice
president but the guy got to the hotel
and started drinking and never quite got
to the vice president's hotel to kill
him but the third assassin Lewis Paine
did get to Suez House who had lived in
Lafayette Park right across
us from the White House and he had just
broken his jaw a week or so before and
was in bed with his jaw wired up so the
assassin came in pretending that he had
medicine for Seward he made his way
upstairs Seward's son was at the top of
the stairs wouldn't let him into the
bedroom he then hit Seward's son with a
revolver made him fracture his skull and
go into a coma went into the bedroom and
had a bowie knife which he slashed
through its other son with the nurse's
aid went to Seward's bed and slashed his
entire cheek off the only thing that
prevented his dying was that he had this
wire from his jaw he then ran down the
stairs and flashed two more people a
bloody massacre in that house so what he
was hoping just as you suggest is that
if he could somehow undo the Vice
President the president and the
Secretary of State that maybe it would
give hope to the dying southern cause at
that last moment and you read in the
epilogue that he survived his son
survived but six weeks later Frances
Seward was dead yeah she's one of the
great characters in this book she was a
woman way ahead of her time Frances so
it very very smart very idealistic
always pushing Seward to do what should
be done rather than what could be done
and I found a fragment in her paper
she's always frail a lot of these 19th
century women had these various vapors
one that never could figure out what
they were but she somehow had this frail
Constitution and after she tended to her
husband and her son for weeks they were
in difficult situation they started
getting better and she wrote in her
papers that she never before had
believed in vicarious suffering but she
thought maybe she had taken on their
illnesses and that she was going to die
and she died sort of inexplicably six
weeks later the book is called team of
rivals the political genius of Abraham
Lincoln the latest by Doris Kearns
Goodwin next call is Matthews County
Virginia go ahead please that you kind
of gave this question to mrs. Goodwin at
the beginning but my question is how
does she come to something fresh in
lincoln biography you know David Herbert
Donald so many other Lincoln scholars
how does someone find something fresh
and then my next question is
it of there's an african-american I'm
also african-american a wonderful
historian who wrote a book about Layton
Lincoln entitled forced into glory um I
was wondering can a particular racial
bias or gender bias
come into one's writing and is that
something fresh that a historian a woman
historian could bring to Lincoln that
maybe some of her male counterparts
could not bring I'd like to think that's
possibly so I mean as I say when I first
started I had no full faith that I could
find something fresh and I think nothing
mattered more to me than when David
Herbert Donald the great Lincoln
biographer of this generation read the
book and said that it was in print said
it was as fresh as if it were the first
book on Lincoln ever published I mean
that's all I needed to hear forever but
I think the only thing that gave me a
chance to possibly say something fresh
was that all these guys that I now call
my guys who would stanton and chase and
baek's because they kept Diaries
they were gossiping about Lincoln and
about each other they had insight into
Lincoln that hadn't always been used in
Lincoln biographies and I think because
I care about their wives and their
families I tried to make them into full
human beings not just policy makers with
Lincoln so it may be that that is partly
a woman perspective as I say in the 19th
century they didn't even think about
wives and families but I think your
question about forced into glory is also
an interesting one because there's been
some comments in recent years but
Lincoln did say some racist things in
the 1850s when he was debating Stephen
Douglas and it's true he wasn't sure
that blacks could actually be on juries
could vote he wasn't sure they could
ever achieve equality in the United
States was kind of a brooding quality to
his statements statements about this is
it not that he didn't wish this would
happen but he wasn't sure we were ever
capable of that and I think what it
shows is that there was just a pervasive
racism in the country as a whole then
very little belief even among
abolitionists that blacks could be equal
to whites and it's a sad commentary I
think on where America was and even more
so it's taken 150 years even beyond that
for us to get to the point where we
finally broke down segregation gave
black
the right to vote and still have
prejudice in this country when did Mary
Todd date Stephen Douglas Mary Todd was
the belle of Springfield when she was a
young girl so it would have been you
know when she was probably 20 22 years
old he was in Illinois and they all were
in the same circle even Lincoln and
Douglas had been in the same circle when
they were young I love to think of Mary
Todd when she was a young girl because
there's so much sadness in her later
life that we tend to think of her as
that older woman who lost three of her
four children of the four children one
died at three years old little Willy
died in the middle of the Civil War ten
Kath her youngest son got at 18 and then
she was eventually put into an asylum by
her oldest son Robert because he didn't
think she was stable enough to live on
her own but when Lincoln first met her
when she was dating Stephen Douglas she
was feisty conversationalist intelligent
well-educated she loved poetry and loved
politics which is very unusual for a
young woman at that time and there's
this wonderful story when Lincoln first
saw her he came up to her seeing her
with all her bows stretched around her
Mary I would love to dance with you in
the worst way and then she laughingly
said he certainly did it was rather
awkward I think but after they were
married she had said that quote she
considered Stephen Douglas to be a
little Little Giant by the side of my
tall Kentuckian and intellectually my
husband towers over Douglas just as he
does physically why'd she say that well
she said that during the period of the
1850s when he was going to be not only
the opponent in 1858 for the Senate race
but was going to be an opponent in 1860
as well for the presidential race and he
had been called Stephen Douglas was very
short and rather Bulls bull looking so
he was called the Little Giant because
he had a huge head and was very very
smart but I think Mary believed in
Lincoln early on which is really quite
something I mean again historians have
been unkind to her in a lot of ways but
she was his partner in the 1850s she had
faith in him she I don't think he needed
her to give him ambition as some people
have suggested he had all the ambition
in the world because ever since he was
young he wanted to accomplish something
so worthy that his story could be told
after he died that would have carried
him through even if he'd never married
anybody I think speaking of rivals did
he have any dealings with Stephen
Douglas when he became president yes a
wonderful thing happened in
terms of their relationship after he
became president Stephen Douglas and
once the war had started
Douglas was close to dying at that point
but he came to the White House and
offered his complete services to Lincoln
which meant that he a former Democrat or
a Democrat at the time was saying this
is not a time for partisanship I'm with
you and that's a moment to remember
because it's the last time the two men
saw each other before Douglas died a few
months later what was he suffering from
he had had presumably difficulties with
alcoholism during his life with drinking
a lot and his body I think was just
ravaged by that terrible pressures he
put it through unlike most people at
that time I'm not sure if he was an
alcoholic but he did he did ravage his
body during that time very few
candidates actually stumped on their own
it wasn't considered dignified but
Douglas had gone all over the country in
1860 trying to win that election and I
think just his body wore down how did
you go about putting all of this
together you refer the books that enroll
later in the program show your library
in Concord mass but but the process of
writing this well you know I once read
an essay by the great historian barbara
tuchman who said it's important when
you're writing especially if you're
doing a lot of research and it's going
to take a long period of time not to get
paralyzed by doing too much research
before you start writing because
otherwise like if I'd gone on for five
or six years doing research and hadn't
written the word I might have said oh no
what am I going to do so instead as soon
as I knew that I was going to be writing
and it took probably a couple years to
figure out that I would write about
these rivals I also was working on that
little memoir on growing up in love with
the Brooklyn Dodgers so I was doing
research on Lincoln writing about the
Brooklyn Dodgers which was a great
combination
but anyways once I figured out that I
had this storyline I knew that I wanted
to start it in May of 1861 the day that
the four arrivals were waiting to hear
the news that they had been nominated
for the presidency of the Republican
Party so I actually wrote that chapter
years and years ago just so I had a
beginning and then I knew I was cycling
back to their earlier lives to bring
them back up to that point so I made
sure to do all my research on their
childhood their young adulthood and
their earlier a lot so I could write
that section so each time I got to a
chapter I would you know maybe spend a
month or so working additionally on it
to make sure I had everything in place
and then write that chapter and that's
why it stretched out to ten years our
book TV bus is travel
around the country and one viewer in
Madison Wisconsin has this question for
Doris Kearns Goodwin
I'm Judy Moore from Madison Wisconsin
and my question for Doris is do you
remember any specific teachers that
taught you to love the stories of
history and could you tell us about them
absolutely can I think in some ways I
had some wonderful teachers in high
school there was a woman named Miss
Austin who actually I went to school in
Long Island New York and she won an
award as the best history teacher in New
York State and what was so great about
her was that she made us feel like she
really cared passionately about these
people when she wrote and told us about
Franklin Roosevelt she had loved him and
when she talked about his death she
cried when she talked about the civil
rights movement in the 50s there was a
sense of her involvement in it all and
she was a dignified wonderful woman and
then when I went to Colby College in
Maine I had this incredible teacher
named Al maverick who somehow was so
involved in political theory and
government and politics that again he
made you feel even that plato was alive
what we were learning about Plato so I
think there's no question that what
history teachers when they are good can
do is to make you realize that you're
not reading about people who are dead
and long gone and who have no interest
in no relevance to your present-day life
you're reading about people who had
passions who had learnings who had
problems who had loves you know who had
lives and if you can feel their life
again just as you feel the people living
in your own lives they come alive and
then you really do care about history
and I was lucky enough to have those two
great teachers in writing wait till next
year what did you learn about yourself I
think the most important thing for me in
writing that book was because my parents
died when I was young my mother when I
was 15 and my father when I was still in
my 20s it was as if somehow they were
not alive in my life in quite the same
way
except all the stories that I had told
to my children and to be able to share
their lives with the people who would
read the book meant so much more to me
than I thought I thought I would simply
be writing a book about baseball somehow
but I think the more I realized it when
I remembered the fact that my father in
some ways was the first teacher I ever
had because as I've often like to say he
taught me how to keep score when I was
only six years old so when he went to
work in New York during the day
could record for him the history of that
afternoon's Brooklyn Dodger game now
when your dad comes home and every
single night he spends two hours with
you as I now realize that I in
excruciating detail we counted every
single play of every inning of the game
that had just taken place that afternoon
makes you think there's something magic
about history and in fact I'm convinced
now and I don't think I knew until I
wrote the memoir that I learned the
narrative art from those sessions with
my dad because at first I would blurt
out the Dodgers won for the Dodgers lost
which took much of the drama from this
to our telling away so I learned you how
to tell a story from beginning to middle
to end one of the photographs in the
book a young doris kearns your sister
Charlotte and you look a lot like your
mom I'd like to think so you know I mean
it's so hard at so many years now from
the time when when she died but the
memories of her having taught me how to
love reading because she was an invalid
she had had rheumatic fever as a child
and she was not really able to leave our
house very much and had the arteries her
doctor said of a seven-year-old when she
was only thirty years old but every
night she would read to me as long as I
could stay awake that childhood dream of
never having to go to sleep and weirdly
I think the only thing I loved as much
as her reading to me was listening to
stories about her girlhood I somehow
became obsessed with the idea that if I
could keep her talking about the days
when she was young and healthy before
the rheumatic fever said in that somehow
this aging process we were witnessing
would be stopped in its tracks so I
would constantly say to her mom tell me
a story about you when you were my age
not realizing how peculiar that was
until I had my own three sons never once
and they said to me mom tell me a story
about you when you were our age she read
slowly and deliberately lingering over
the passages she liked helping me feel
the rhythm of the language the pleasure
of well-chosen words she modulated her
voice to reflect the different
characters in the pace of their
narration and he also said that her
voice was softer than yours right right
well I have a very loud voice she used
to tease me that when I be out with my
friends playing on the street she could
hear me wherever I was so I'm afraid I
was never very shy or never very quiet
how did you get the nickname bubbles
well my father liked to think that I was
enthusiastic about things and I would
sort of get excited whatever we were
going someplace or excited to go to a
ball game or excited about anything so
he thought that was a bubbly thing so it
was kind of embarrassing though and he
would write me letters and
camp dear bubbles and everybody knew
what he was calling me and you brought
along a photograph that is also in the
book wait till next year your home you
know what was it on that was on southern
Avenue in Rockville Center what was
wonderful in those days is the homes
were so close to one another with this
tiny patch of lawn so that my best
friend had a window right next to mine
across this narrow driveway we could
talk to each other at night when we were
supposed to be asleep was your bedroom
on the second floor
it was indeed it was indeed hers about
the second floor right there and you
know in those days in New York in the
1850s you in the nineteen eighteen
fifties in the nineteen fifties I've not
battled in the 1950s there were giants
Dodger and Yankee fans all together she
was a Yankee fan I was a Dodger fan
across the street with giant fans
baseball was the abiding passion and it
was shared by everybody on the block
Michael Francis Aloysius Kearns
that a great name my father's name I'll
tell you that man I loved so much I mean
he had had such a difficult childhood he
grew up in Brooklyn his father was a
fireman he had had a little brother who
was six years old when he was can a
little sister who was - mother was
pregnant and his mother died and then
his little brother was hit by a trolley
car he was left with his little sister
and his father eventually killed himself
and his little sister when she was 16
years old died in the dentist's chair
from some faulty anesthesia now you
would think that that would create a man
who didn't have a life force in him and
had a sad mentality or a melancholy
spirit he was the most optimistic
outgoing twinkle in his eye somehow he
served not only survived but he gave
affirmative life to all of us it was the
gift he gave to me to love life that I
will never forget him for you write a
lot about your First Holy Communion in
the book we've got a defining moment
growing up well it certainly was a
defining moment because two things had
happened one is that right before by
Holy Communion roy campanella the Dodger
catcher came to my town I was so excited
it would be the first time I'd ever see
a Dodger player outside of Ebbets Field
however it was announced that he was
going to speak in a Protestant church
and I when you brought up as a Catholic
you think if he was deaf foot in the
Protestant church you'll be struck dead
at the threshold so I went into the
church however with my father 9 he said
don't worry about it he's speaking in
the parish hall we're sitting in chairs
and it's going to be fine but I was
worried still that I had somehow traded
the life of my Everlast
soul for this night with roy campanella
so when i went to my first confession i
had to tell the priest what i thought
might have been a sin i told him right
up front i figured strategically get it
over with but the priest tell me exactly
what my dad had said don't worry it's
not a sin you weren't in a religious
service but then unfortunately he said
and what else my child and then I had to
acknowledge that I wished harm to others
namely I wished various New York Yankee
players would break arms legs and ankles
so the Dodgers could win their first
World Series I remember the priests said
to me how often do you make these wishes
and I had to say every night when I send
my prayers but then he said to me look I
love the Dodgers as much as you do you
don't have to wish harm and others to
make them when some day they will win
fairly and squarely do you understand oh
yes I said then as I left luckily he was
a baseball loving priest he said say a
special prayer for our Brooklyn Dodgers
so no way to forget that first communion
1949 in 1957 the nine seasons included
the Dodgers the Yankees and the Giants
one of them competing for the World
Series and then the Giants and the
Dodgers left in a short period of time
do they not did they not oh boy I'll
tell you it was such a blow to those of
us who loved baseball every year we
would argue who's the best centerfielder
who's the best first baseman and
suddenly these two teams were gone
Walter O'Malley he took them away became
like a tyrant in our community I didn't
follow baseball again for so many years
so saddened by the loss of the Dodgers
until I finally moved to Harvard College
and went to Fenway Parkinson became an
irrational Red Sox fan let's get our
next call from San Diego go ahead please
well I was wondering um about this
theory that's just come out that in
another book that Lincoln was a
depressive I just find that very hard to
believe as someone who's had some
experience in my family with depression
there's just not the energy I don't
think to overcome it the way this theory
says that Lincoln did and I wondered
what your your rough findings on that
and what you think about Lincoln having
been a depressive you know I came away
with a somewhat different feeling I
think he was born with a melancholy
temperament as opposed to an optimistic
temperament in fact a great friend of
mine Jerry Kagan has written a wonderful
book studying children from 0 to 20 to
show that you can tell early on which
one of the two though
children our life can change things
obviously for them but he understood
well his sorrows and his melancholy he
knew how to get himself out of it
he had a remarkable sense of humor when
he told a story he could do that he knew
to go to conversation when he was lonely
even in the presidency when things were
anxious he would go to a play to be able
to get his mind out of what he was doing
and there's really only two significant
depressive episodes in his life the
first one after his great love first and
Rutledge died an understandable
depression any one of us would have been
in it the second one three things came
together and he seemed to feel like his
life force was not going forward he'd
broken his engagement Mary Todd he had
somehow lost his best friend Joshua
speed who was leaving town and his
political career seemed to be going down
and so he did fall into a depression so
deep that people worried that he might
be suicidal they took scissors and
knives away from him but he told his
friends speed at that time you know he
said I would just as soon die but I
haven't yet done anything to be
remembered by and I believed that dream
powered him through all the failures in
his life and I totally agree with you
that he had terrific energy he was the
one actually who sustained the people
during the worst days of the civil war
more than his colleagues more than his
cabinet guys who weren't depressed he
was the one who kept them going so I
think being a melancholy temperament is
different from having chronic depression
an email from Bruce Tennant Doris
Goodwin from Long Beach California
wondering considering your close
association with President Lyndon
Johnson and with the release over the
last couple of years of his White House
tapes how do you ultimately view his
political acumen as compared to that of
Abraham Lincoln I think there was a lot
of similarities in their ability to make
people come around to their point of
view but Johnson of course had a much
more hands-on policy with the Congress I
mean those tapes are just fantastic
showing for example in the 1964 when he
was trying to get the Civil Rights Act
through the Congress the tapes show him
talking to Everett Dirksen Dirksen of
course is the Republican minority leader
he knows he needs him to break the
filibuster on the Civil Rights Act and
so at first he's promising everything
under the Sun you come with me Dirksen
you'll get dams you know you have a
feeling every part of Illinois will be
filled with public projects but then
essentially what he says to him you know
if you come with me on this bill 99
years from now the NAACP will be flying
your banner and in fact then 200 years
from now he said schoolchildren will
know only two names Abraham Lincoln and
Everett Dirksen so in other words he
knew how to persuade people to come to
his side and those tapes are fantastic
you know there's a very funny story when
I was some years ago at a conference
with the former CEO of Pepsi Cola Don
Kendall and he came over to me said now
I know you knew Lyndon Johnson when you
were a young girl but I have a story I
bet you don't know and he told me that
when Nixon first got into the presidency
he asked Kendal to go to the ranch to
talk to Johnson about some private
matter and he said Johnson was working
on his memoirs looked up grumpily and
said how am I supposed to remember what
happened 20 years ago 30 years ago the
only chapters that are any good at all
are the ones we had this little tape
machine in my Oval Office I used to
press a button
verbatim conversations so those chapters
really come alive so he says to cancel
you go back and tell your good friend
Nixon that there's nothing more
important than a taping system and
thereby Lyndon Johnson contributes to
Richard Nixon's downfall I love that
story from Kendall in the book you write
about after he left the presidency
Lyndon Johnson said that how is it
possible that all these people could be
so ungrateful to me after I had given
him given them so much
I think what hurt him the most was that
he knew how much he had done for civil
rights he knew how much he had done for
poor people he knew he had done how much
for education and yet in those last
months and years of his presidency
his public opinion polls had gone down
and it seemed like people had forgotten
all the great things he'd accomplished
I'd like to believe that before he died
had begun to sense some of that but I
don't think he did sadly I think if he
had only lived a little longer
historians now are putting him higher
and higher up in the public opinion in
the historians called knowing that those
great achievements Medicare aid to
education the Civil Rights Act the
Voting Rights Act probably would not
have happened without his great skill
with the Congress but he only lived four
years after he left the presidency did
his depression begin
On January 20th 1969 I believe it did I
mean here was a man who was so intensely
involved in public life in politics he
couldn't live without it I mean down at
the ranch he liked to replicate in a
certain sense what he had at the White
House but no longer would there be
meanings in the morning for which bills
would go to which committee on the hill
it would rather be which cows we're
going to get the itch medicine or which
tractors were going to fix which fields
its
wasn't enough to sustain him and you
really felt I did when I was talking to
him as if that will to live had been
diminished he had the most fantastic
life Lady Bird Johnson and I think
loving her and loving those kids kept
him going but without that I think he
would have sadly just been happy enough
to go away Lady Bird Johnson said that
the cherry had turned into pumpkin and
all the aides turned into mice oh wow I
don't know that statement that's a great
statement she was the most remarkable
woman it wasn't easy to be with Lyndon
Johnson but she kept her dignity and she
once said to me you know she I could
have married some guy a stockbroker and
lived in Austin and maybe he would have
been home at 5:00 at night but Lyndon
has shown me a world and I'm very
grateful for that I remember one time
that whenever he'd be going off on
something or saying something crazy like
so-and-so is a member of the Communist
Party she could just put her hand on his
knee and say now Lyndon you don't really
mean that and all the tension would ease
out of him why did you write Lyndon
Johnson in the American dream I wasn't
planning to write a book about him it
was just that he had spent such a long
time talking to me about his earlier
life and then he died obviously before
he was able to get back to his childhood
or his Senate years and I had all this
stuff and I wanted to be able to share
it and so that became my first book I'd
originally majored in constitutional law
I probably wouldn't have become a
presidential historian had it not been
for this privilege of working with him
now there's a story somewhere that he
crawled into bed with you I mean I told
the story so here's what happened I mean
he would wake up in the morning and in
that loneliness he wanted to talk I mean
he just talked and talked he couldn't
bear being alone even when he took a nap
he wanted to have somebody sitting
outside the room so that if he coughed
you know he would know you were there
and so sometimes he would come into my
room in the morning and I would get up
knowing he was coming in and he would
then bring the covers up to his cheeks
or his chin and talk to me and it was as
I say a wonderful way to hear about the
past to see a person's ability to be an
actual human being as well as the
president United States and he was a
very powerful president I'd like to
share with the audience the speech that
he delivered and there's a there two
photographs from the book the vantage
point his address in the Oval Office and
then the next day the headline in the
Chicago Tribune LBJ won't run was March
31st 1968
it's just under two minutes we'll roll
that and come back and get the story
behind his decision not to seek another
term I have concluded that I should not
permit the president to become involved
in the partisan divisions that are
developing in this political year with
America's sons in the field far away
with America's future under challenge
right here at home with our hopes and
the world's hopes for peace in the
balance every day I do not believe that
I should devote an hour hour day of my
time to any personal partisan costs or
to any duties other and the awesome
duties of this office of presidency of
your country accordingly I shall not
seek and I will not accept the
nomination of my party for another term
as your president but let men everywhere
know how it that a strong and a
confident and a vigilant America stand
ready tonight to seek an honorable peace
and stand ready tonight to defend an
honored call whatever the price whatever
the burden whatever the sacrum that Duty
may require thank you for listening good
night and God bless all of you George
Kearns Goodwin in your book you say
there was an air of euphoria in the
Capitol the next day even Johnson seemed
pleased and then you tell the story
about Johnson's visit with President
Truman two months later
President Johnson commenting on Truman's
decision ability to make a decision and
then stick with it not to look back you
know I think just to go to the Truman
thing what Johnson so honored about
Truman was when he had to drop the
atomic bomb that he made that decision
on the basis of the best facts that were
at his disposal maybe he might have made
it differently if he'd known other
things but he never looked back he
didn't lose sleep
whereas Lyndon Johnson in those months
and months before he left the presidency
would wake up every night and wonder
about his did the bombs drop in the
right place have I done the right thing
he was tortured by that and I think what
happened it led up to this withdrawal
was he began to feel that the only way
maybe that the war would come to an end
would be if he took himself out of the
political process because if he tried to
negotiate a peace people would say he
was just doing it for his next election
and at that point a president is
thinking about history more than they
are thinking even about winning another
term and at the same time he felt like
he was paralyzed that people were not
able to deal with the Congress and the
way he was before and he had a sense he
had had a grandmother who had had a
stroke and when he was a little kid he
was just terrified to watch her because
she couldn't move and he began to have a
dream in those weeks before he withdrew
from the race that he too had had a
stroke and was lying in the Red Room
just where Woodrow Wilson who had had a
stroke during his presidency lay and
that he could hear all the advisors
outside dividing up his power taking it
away from him which symbolically was
happening to him in those last months
and used to have to wake up from the
dream he said and go see Woodrow
Wilson's picture on the wall to remind
himself that Wilson was Wilson or that
he was Lyndon Johnson he did not have a
stroke and he was alive but I think
metaphorically he felt that the
political process was paralyzed because
of the war and that if he took himself
out of it maybe he could do better for
the country and maybe the country would
remember him better what was that your
like for you well what had happened is I
had not originally started to work for
him I was put to the labor department
after that article I wrote about him and
worked for this wonderful man Secretary
of Labor Willard works and after Johnson
gave this speech and then after Martin
Luther King was killed a few months
later Johnson was going to make a major
speech to the country on civil rights
just as he had after the Selma
demonstrations and Willard works was one
of the people working on the speech so
giving ideas for it so works and I had
helped him a little bit on it and I was
so excited that he was going to do
that maybe turn civil-rights in a
positive way after Martin Luther King's
death we had a function at the White
House shortly after that Johnson came up
to me and he'd always would say
something to me in that year we met him
as White House fellows young when you
ask me a question you know as if he knew
our past and that day I just said I wish
you'd given this speech and he teased me
said you're always criticizing me aren't
you and then the next day he called up
Willie Horton said I want her to come
over here and work for me for the rest
of her White House fellowship and I was
sorry to leave words interesting as I
don't want to leave you because I
thought he was great there was no idea
what I do in the White House but works
rightly said you've got to take this
chance you've got to know him so I went
to the White House worked from those
last months of my White House fellowship
and stayed on until January 69 money
left and mostly I just talked to him and
listened to mostly listened not talked
Springfield Massachusetts
you're next for Doris Kearns Goodwin the
wonderful program thanks for c-span a
couple of things they've growing up in
Massachusetts as a Red Sox fan have had
some pretty interesting confession
actually in 1978 as a young man I know
what you mean
but after that with your brief reason I
was calling was actually about the
Lyndon Johnson about the the things were
t8 used the CIA to look at the Martin
Luther King's private life is kind of
always wondered what a contradiction
that was because he was so you know
ahead on civil rights and what exactly
was the thinking behind that or where
was there any or was it just I guess
Jagger Hoover was a big part of this so
I think I think you're right I mean I
think J Edgar Hoover was a force unto
his own right but that doesn't mean that
the presidents didn't have a
responsibility to rein him in but that
was Hoover specialty to look into the
private lives of these public figures in
case some dirt could be found so that
they could be discredited if you didn't
like what they were doing you know and
for people like Hoover the civil rights
movement was a threat partly because it
might have meant a lot of people
gathering together and there could be
some violence etc but also maybe because
they didn't like the substance of it so
even you know to Kennedy and through
Johnson there was this tendency to look
into Martin Luther King
just in case they might need something
and you're absolutely right for somebody
who believes in civil rights and it
advanced it so much the idea that that
kind of
the liberties is being violated is not a
tenable thing since you brought up the
Red Sox can you explain this photograph
oh this is a great photograph okay this
has a little bit of a story to it the
guy on the this guy on the crutches
holding crutches is one of my sons
Michael who's my middle son and the
person in the center is my youngest son
Joey and Joey had just come back from
Iraq at this point he graduated from
Harvard College in June of o1 and
history and literature and ended up
instead of going on to graduate school
that fall after September 11 ended up
joining the army instead for what will
be a four-year commitment with the first
Armored Division and as soon as he
finished basic training and officers
Candidate School he was sent to Iraq
where he was a platoon leader in a slum
sector of Baghdad for a year and after
the first Armored Division left and went
to back to Germany their home base he
came home to have his ACL operated on
that's why he's on crutches because he
had he had torn his knee and the Red Sox
found out that he had won a Bronze Star
for valor while he was over there so
they invited him to throw out the first
ball at Fenway Park it was so funny and
he said he was more nervous that night
than when an RPG went one foot over his
head which was the first we'd parents
learned that an RPG had gone over his
head and all week long his guy friends
are calling up these Harvard kids are
now you know investment bankers so they
were able to buy tickets on eBay they
all come back to watch him and they're
saying him Joey don't embarrass us you
better hit a strike and I said well Joey
it doesn't matter you know you're on
crutches you've just won the Bronze Star
they're going to have up there saying
that you were in Iraq he said mom you
don't understand it's a guy thing so all
week on his crutches he's practicing and
somehow managed to hit the plate it was
a wonder for all he's as irrational as I
am even in Iraqi be staying up all night
to listen to the Red Sox games when they
were in the playoff the year before how
did you feel when they finally won the
series it was astonishing I mean it
still feels good leap or not I can wake
up in the morning and I can still
remember what it felt like I mean as a
baseball fan my whole life I've only had
two World Series the Dodgers in 1955 and
then the Red Sox in 2004 and maybe it's
even better that way because it's more
intense although sometimes I wish my
father had been born in the Bronx
instead of Brooklyn I would have been a
lot happier but nonetheless there was
something about that first World Series
to share with my mother and my father
and
the second one to share with my three
sons the minute it happened I mean we
were able to talk to Joey in Iraq we
were able to talk to our son Michael and
Ramon and our son Richard in California
and that's what's so incredible about
baseball it really does allow you to go
through the generations you know I've
often said that sometimes when I sit
with my boys at Fenway Park now we have
season tickets and I go to
unconscionable number of games but I
love it and I can sit there with them
and sometimes close my eyes and imagine
that I'm a young girl once more with my
father by my side at Ebbets Field with
Roy Campanella down they are Duke Snider
or Pee Wee Reese or Jackie Robinson and
somehow then when I see my son sitting
there where my father wants that it's
almost like an invisible loyalty and
love it links them they never saw my
father they never saw their grandfather
but through all the stories I have told
they've come to know his heart and soul
and baseball does that and that's I
think why I love it so much how do you
think history will view the war in Iraq
I think what's going to be very hard for
the war in Iraq to be viewed in a
positive way is whether or not there was
a rationale for going in there even
forgetting the weapons of mass
destruction which clearly was not the
rationale but if there was a larger goal
that the administration had in mind to
create a stronghold of democracy in the
Middle East history will have to
determine whether that was a good thing
if you don't tell the people what your
purpose is I think it's very hard for
the people to sustain the support for
the war I mean it's interesting even
Lincoln questioned the rationale for the
mexican-american war saying that the
president Polk had instigated for his
own purposes and that has always cast a
doubt onto that war was very successful
we got a lot of territory but these
questions about how we started it but I
think more importantly even if one says
the rationale was correct at some level
then obviously the fact that we hadn't
prepared for it and well enough with
enough numbers I mean when my son first
got there for example was right after
mission was accomplished and he had a
peaceful reconstruction mission he was
so excited he had an Iraqi translator he
was going into the Iraqis homes within
days the security broke down the looting
had taken place
no more translator no more Iraqi homes
and instead of a peaceful mission which
he had hoped to accomplish he had three
duties checkpoint duty weapon searches
and lastly he had to take his platoon
out as a target so the insurgents would
shoot them so they
could kill the insurgents in turn but
even saying all that for him he never
second-guessed going into the army what
a great decision it was you know here's
a kid from affluent conquered Harvard
College he's seen kids in a world he
never would have seen those twenty-four
kids in his platoon high school
graduates only and he melded with them
he became their leader so he's a better
man I sometimes think we've lost
something by not having the draft
because I think it makes men out of
these young boys and women and and it
makes everybody participate in the war
and I feel so sad when I see those
individual people's names in the
newspapers now and know that the
families don't have that same sense they
did in World War two that everybody knew
somebody overseas and I think we're
going to have to rethink that if we're
going to have these missions abroad next
call comes to us from Scotts Valley
California go ahead please yes first
have a comment and then two questions
the comment is if people haven't read it
already no ordinary time is an excellent
looks very very much and I really highly
recommend it to everybody by two
questions please jot these down the
first question is and I haven't gotten
your book yet but I plan on doing so did
you cover the massacre at Fort Pillow
and President Lincoln's response to it
and the second question how do you think
President Lincoln would view the real
possibility of a black woman becoming
president of the United States in 2008
well I can try and answer both questions
I did cover the massacre at Fort Pillow
to some extent I mean what was so
important about that is that after this
massacre took place this was a massacre
of black soldiers at Fort Pillow there
was a call for retaliation so that we
would somehow in the North begin to
Massacre southern soldiers their
southern people in return for that and
Lincoln was very hesitant about that at
first because he didn't believe it was
right to somehow retaliate against some
individuals who may not have been part
of the massacre but finally he did issue
a retaliatory order and and just hoped
that it wouldn't have to be used which
indeed was pretty much what happened and
I think as far as what Lincoln would
think about a black woman being
president he would be delighted I think
there's no question as long as she
shared the values that he thought I mean
the most important thing
he thought about a government that was a
democracy like ours was that it somehow
cleared away the artificial weights that
rested on people that prevented them
from rewriting to the level of their own
talent I mean he saw himself in a way as
an example of what was so extraordinary
about America he was able to push his
way up to the top but I think he would
see in modern society with the problems
with education and the problems with
poverty that there are whole groups of
people that cannot push their way up to
the top and would want to have somebody
whose value was to help them go through
that process so they could exercise with
whatever talents they have discipline
they have hard work to be able to get to
the level of their ability next call
appropriately enough comes from
Springfield Illinois go ahead please
greetings from Lincoln Springfield yes
indeed on 140 fifth anniversary of his
election oh wow I hadn't thought about
that that's right pretty hard doors I
have a brief statement and two questions
there is a stained-glass depiction of
Lincoln reaching out to sewers friend
Archbishop John Hughes in a Roman
Catholic cathedral six blocks through
south of the old State Capitol now is
there any evidence linking the
archbishop was sewers the doctrine of
higher law and will Seward be vindicated
with the confirmation of the fifth
Catholic justice oh boy how interesting
I didn't know about that stained-glass
window but Archbishop Hughes was a great
friend of Seward's and in fact during
the Civil War went over to England and
did some yeoman work for the
administration by being over there you
know it's actually very funny when
Seward was running earlier for the
Senate his great boss Thurlow weed had
also been a friend of Archbishop Hughes
and had a picture of Hughes in his house
and went when a whole bunch of nativists
you know at that time there were a lot
of people who were very anti-catholic
came to his house and he needed them to
vote for Seward and so he told them that
Archbishop Hughes was simply some you
know like George Washington and enrolled
or something that it wasn't really the
hughes of the Catholic religion
what you're saying about the higher law
is what it's true what what Seward said
in a famous speech in 1850 and what he
was really saying was that there's a
higher law even in the Constitution that
would guide us toward anti-slavery in
other words God's law or a morality war
lore and a lot of people were frightened
by that thought but there's a question
of whether or not he was church and
state he would be kind of comfortable
today in some ways with what's going on
because even as a young governor in New
York State he worried that the Catholics
weren't getting enough education that
they were living in poverty so he talked
about public aid to these Catholic
schools something that again is very
much in controversy today but it hurt
him at the time because the nativist
wanted nothing to do with helping
Catholics in any way
where was the Whig one in Chicago oh I
don't know I mean it's not there now so
I don't know what I mean I probably knew
when I wrote this book or when I
finished it a couple weeks ago when it
was where it was exactly but it doesn't
exist in Chicago anymore and it was
constructed exactly for the convention
and they say it was called the wigwam
because the great Chiefs met there so
they called it the wigwam and it was
part of what allowed Chicago to get the
convention because they promised that
they would build a structure precisely
for it what's amazing is when the
committee the Republican Committee
National Committee met to figure out
where they should hold a convention
Seward wanted it in New York
Chace wanted it in Ohio Bates wanted in
Missouri and since Lincoln was a dark
horse
they all said all right let's have it in
Illinois we don't have to worry about
anyone there but Lincoln knew the
importance of having it in Chicago and
in fact he got the railroads to give
discounted fare so people could get to
Chicago and then he was able to pack the
hall with his supporters and in fact one
of dates supporters later said if we
want it in Missouri and they lost by one
vote it's possible Lincoln wouldn't been
the president to names the figure
prominently Lyman Trumbull and Norman
Judd who were they
well Lyman Trumbull ran against Lincoln
for the first Senate race in 1855 and he
had actually been a former you know the
Republican Party is made up of all these
various elements people who were former
Whigs and former Democrats former
Liberty Party and so in those days the
state legislature is choosing the
senator and Lincoln had the majority of
the votes like 47 almost he only needed
with five more votes in order to win
that
nation for the Senate in 1855 Trumbull
supporters he was a former Democrat
we're not willing to go with Lincoln not
that they didn't like him but because he
was a Whig and so they held out and they
held out and they held out it looked
like there'd be a stalemate and Lincoln
was worried that if neither one of them
won that the third candidate who might
win was more Pro southern more
pro-slavery so he turned all 47 of his
votes over to five votes of trumble's
allowing Trumbull to become a senator
and his friends couldn't figure out how
in the world can you do that Mary was so
upset with trumble's wife that she
hardly spoke to her again in her life
but Lincoln went to his victory party
that night shook his hand and as a
result of not making an enemy out of a
man like Trumbull Trumbull and Norman
Judd who'd been one of those five become
his great supporters in 1858 and again
in 1860 a Norman judge is a key figure
in his winning the election in 1860 so
it shows that if you somehow don't treat
the people who hurt you in the past with
enmity but somehow can bring them back
into your life they will age you later
on if I have this right Stephen Douglas
is the Democratic nominee John
Breckinridge is a southern candidate you
also have the know-nothings
which held a convention nominating John
Bell of Tennessee and Edward Everett of
Massachusetts that's correct so the the
Democratic Party was really split in
three you had Lincoln as the Republican
candidate and then you have Douglass as
the predominant Democratic candidate but
then these other two union party so more
conservative in different different
aspects so that's one of the reasons why
Lincoln was able to win the election
because of the split in the other party
and what was the final vote count II
remember it was it was not not very
great it was enough at the very at the
very end what Lincoln was afraid of was
that if New York with its great
electoral votes went for Douglass it was
very possible they might because there
were a lot of Irish Catholics in the
city there were a lot of conservative
merchants in the cities who wanted to
keep trading with the south didn't want
slavery to be such an issue and Thurlow
weed and Seward did yeoman work in New
York even though he was told like at
midnight you've won the election don't
worry he said until I here in New York
totals because if he'd lost New York
then it would have been thrown into the
House of Representatives there would
have been no majority so and you write
in the book and there's just sketching
to to characterize if the assassination
threat threats as pride
Elect why was this embarrassing to
Abraham Lincoln not the assassination
threat but this caricature well what
happened is he was told in Philadelphia
that when the train passed through
Baltimore where there are a lot of
secessionist that there might be a mob
attack on the train and they think they
thought he better go in in the dead of
night so that people wouldn't know he
was coming through so he did do that he
did not wear a Scottish cloak and Cal
fit like this cartoon portrayed but
somehow the word got around that he had
dressed up in this disguise come into
Washington under the dead of night and
it looked like here's the
president-elect coming to Washington and
he can't even come on an own power and
he wished then that he had actually
taken the risk and gone through
Baltimore in daylight even if the
trainer that attacked Las Vegas you're
next glad clay how are you doing today
the reason I called up in a letter on
November 21st 1864 Abraham Lincoln wrote
as a result of the war corporations have
become enthroned and an era of
corruption in high places will follow
the money power of the country will
endeavor to prolong its rule by preying
upon the prejudice of the people until
all wealth is concentrated in a few
hands and the Republic is destroyed I
was wondering if you heard about that
I don't know that letter that's an
extraordinary letter though do you know
who he wrote it to actually I don't I I
picked it up in a book that I was
reading one time and that was the quote
at the beginning of the chapter of the
book wow I love I love the certain of
non American history and they had a
things you don't know about America well
you know what what is true is that
obviously early on in the war for
example they had to let contracts out to
suppliers to make knapsacks and to make
weapons and to make all sorts of you
know machinery for the war and obviously
middlemen made away with scandalous
profits and produced knapsacks that fell
apart in the rain and produce pistols
that didn't work so you could see some
of the worries that we might have even
today but the interesting thing is that
Cameron who was then the Secretary of
War was about to be censured by the
Congress for letting these contracts out
to these companies at that time and
Cameron's whole career he felt would be
destroyed forever but Lincoln stood up
for his first Secretary of War wrote a
letter to the Congress saying you know
if Cameron is at fault
of us are at fault myself and the entire
cabinet was simply a problem in the
early days of the war of the chaos and
we have to do something to start getting
the weapons made and mistakes were made
but there's no question but that war
produces power and produces centralized
power it produces more goods for
corporations and eventually what you're
saying might be true but I would love to
find such a letter that's fascinating
Michiko Kakutani from New York Times in
her review of the book that was dated
October 25th said that in team of rivals
and I'm just going to read a couple of
sentences she skims lightly over her
subjects more pragmatic political
maneuverings and his troubling
utterances about race indeed miss
Goodwin's Lincoln often resembles Carl
Sandburg's Man of Steel and velvet a
wise and strong leader for the ages
whose legacy in his Goodwin's words
belong not only to America but to the
ages to be revered and sung throughout
all the time do you think you skim over
his I don't think so I mean I do think
that I came away with a very positive
feeling toward Lincoln I don't think I
could easily write about somebody like
Hitler or Stalin as some other great
historians can and live with him day by
day and that's partly why I chose him
but there's no question that he has
flaws and the flaw has come out in the
book I mean he was much too patient to
general McClellan early on kept him on
too long there's no question that his
understandings of equality were not as
spacious as one would have hoped not
even as spacious as salmon chases were
and there's no question that there are
other things he did just as for Franklin
Roosevelt as much as I loved and revered
him and respected him as a leader his
incarceration at the japanese-americans
was one of the greatest violations and
civil liberties his failure to bring
more Jewish refugees into the country
before Hitler closed the door forever
was something that was sad and when the
more you care about the person you're
writing about the sadder you are about
their flaws but every leader has flaws
but in Lincoln's case I think most
historians would argue that his
overwhelming strengths are far greater
than his flaws and that's certainly what
I found to be too as well
Overland Park Kansas you're next good
afternoon thank you for taking my call
miss Kearns if you were interviewing
President Lincoln on c-span what would
you ask him about his presidency what
would you ask him personally
and number three what
would he say about how well people have
viewed his place in history these many
decades later in view of his modesty oh
boy great questions I mean I think what
I would ask him maybe about his
presidency would be to talk to him about
what he might have done after the war I
mean that's the big unknown question of
history had he lived would
reconstruction have been different how
would he have treated the south how
would he assured that black American
still had the right even as he brought
the South back into the Union everybody
wonders if Lincoln hadn't been killed as
he was would things have been different
so I'd love him to speculate on what he
thinks he would have been like but I
think personally if I had an hour with
him I would just say to him please tell
me some of your great stories I mean
Lincoln was so much of a storyteller so
gifted but that's part of how his rise
to power took place even as a young
lawyer he would travel around the
circuit for two months in the spring and
two months in the fall and when he went
from courthouse to courthouse if they
knew he were in town people would come
from miles around to listen to him stand
up by a fireplace and tell one story
after another and they say that that sad
face of his once he started telling a
story his eyes would Sparkle and his
whole life force would be shown so I
would just give anything to listen to
him tell me one story after another and
then I think as far as your last
question goes what would he think about
the fact that his name has stretched so
far I mean I think Lincoln would be
astonished as much as he wanted to be
remembered after he died and as much as
that dream powered him through all the
failures in his life and it was never
simply for office or power he wanted to
somehow be able to say that he had made
a difference in the lives of the people
of his generation which he surely did
but when I found for example and then I
was able to end the book with it a quote
from Leo Tolstoy the great storyteller
of history that made it seem that
Lincoln's life had gone so much further
than even Lincoln could have imagined I
bet Lincoln would have blushed the story
was that Leo Tolstoy went into the
Caucasus and it was some years prior to
1908 this article was written in the New
York world and he went there and he met
with a whole bunch of rude barbarians
who hardly knew anything about the West
and they asked Tolstoy to tell stories
of the great men of history so he talked
about Alexander and Frederick the Great
and and they said to him no when you
finished you haven't told us about that
man we
want to know about that man who spoke
with a voice of thunder who laughed like
the sunrise tell us of Abraham Lincoln
Tolstoy said he was astonished that
Lincoln's name had reached into these
rude barbarians who hardly knew about
America they said all we know about
America is it this place that it's so
far from here
that if we as youth journeyed there we'd
be old men when we got there and then
Tolstoy concluded why did they want to
know what had they heard about Lincoln
why was he so great he wasn't a great
general like Napoleon not a great
statesman like Frederick the gray but
Tolstoy concluded he was a humanitarian
as brought us the world and it was his
character that will last and Tolstoy
predicted that even two centuries from
now people would know more about Lincoln
than we know then because it would last
forever
I think if Lincoln heard that it would
make him so happy but his modesty would
say that can't be true you have a sketch
in the book of Lincoln's office in the
White House where is that what happened
in those days is the office and it was
in the White House Office and the
Cabinet Room were the same so unlike
today we've got the Oval Office and then
you've got the Cabinet Room separate
there was a big long table where the
cabinet would meet it was a pretty
simple setting so he had a big chair
that he'd like to sit in he had a desk
where he sat and then this table where
they'd all be arranged in terms of
primacy Secretary of State sitting
closest to the president the Secretary
of Treasury next in terms of which
office was most powerful but the
incredible thing about the White House
and his office in those days a jobseeker
could race into the White House and
simply go to Lincoln and talk to him
noses the days before civil service and
then he also would have receptions in
the White House where anybody could come
back woodsman or diplomat to life the
backwoodsman it was said would drag
their mud in they would actually snip
parts of the carpet to take home as a
souvenir and people on Lincoln's staff
would say to a Lincoln you can't waste
time talking to all these people and he
said it's my public opinion bath I need
to do it I need to remember the great
popular assemblage from which I've come
you know I think about that now in terms
of in recent decades the White House has
become so much of a cocoon and it's so
insulated partly for security but partly
because of the way it's run but I think
the reason we have these second term
blues with our presidents is that they
have lost touch with the people their
first election they just come from the
people and then the second election they
win it and then all the people have been
with them have also lost touch with
ordinary people
and Lincoln understood the importance of
that he had no problem if public opinion
polls were out today he would listen to
them
he wouldn't say they don't mean anything
he would educate and shape the public
hopefully not be constrained by it but
he used to say with universal sentiment
anything is possible without it nothing
in a democracy the people's opinion
matters so he would try and keep touch
and he did that he understood the mood
of the people just like FDR did somehow
it's that intuitive mystical sense that
a leader has in today's day and age
though we don't have anymore recordings
that we know of in the White House we
have emails and computers maybe not as
many letters Ravel historians look at
this year a hundred years from now I
think it's going to be much much harder
for them to recapture what people were
feeling and thinking they'll have much
more stuff to go through which might
indeed be paralyzing but they won't have
what you get in a diary entry or a
letter I mean what a letter means
usually if you are writing to your wife
or your daughter you're keeping a diary
maybe you're sometimes thinking of
history in the 1850s and 60s but mostly
you're just writing your raw emotions
and then you're reading them as a
historian 150 years later and you really
can feel what they were feeling at that
time people aren't writing letters the
art of letter writing is no longer there
I mean they taught each other how to
write letters when they were young think
of the fact that husbands and wives are
away from each other so much of the time
you go on a trip to Europe you're gone
for a year if you're not with your
husband or wife
so letters writing is the only means of
communication no phone Telegraph is
certainly not going to do it so they
learned how to write letters in a way
that I'm not even sure we know how to
write you know one might when my son was
in Iraq and I tried to write in his
office and I could and Here I am
supposedly a writer and it was hard to
figure out what to tell him I was
finally reduced sometimes to thinking
about Lincoln pardoned the soldier today
who fell asleep and that's what I would
be reduced to tell him meanwhile however
my other son who's 14 months older than
he and who was in that picture that we
saw earlier holding his crutches when he
threw out the ball at Fenway Park he is
himself wanting to be a writer he wrote
to his brother every single day wrote a
handwritten note every day and you know
when you bring up your kids and the two
of them are fighting in the back of the
car when they're young since they were
almost like Irish twins there was a
sense in which once I knew that he and
his brother had become that close that's
all that mattered I knew we'd be gone
someday but they'd have each other
I'm
the books by Doris Kearns Goodwin wait
till next year which came out in 1997
and Fitzgerald's and the Kennedy
nightmare 89 Evan and the latest team of
rivals next call is Santa Barbara
California go ahead hi there um great
show and I just wanted to get this
Goodwin's opinion on something
in article 5 of the Constitution it says
that there's only two groups of
Americans who can propose change to the
country and one group is Congress and
the other is a captioning and right now
in the 9th Circuit Court of Appeals is a
federal lawsuit called Walker vs.
members of Congress and it shows that
all the applications for an article v
convention are registered with personnel
and they're failing to carry out their
constitutional obligation and issue the
call and I was just wondering what you
thought of that and if you think it's
time for an article v convention you
know I don't know what you're talking
about and I'm interested to hear about
that I mean you're absolutely right
though I think the framers decided that
since constitutional amendments were
such an important process there needed
to be two possible ways of initiating
them one could be the Congress or one
could be the state conventions as you
say in almost all cases in history it's
been a very onerous process to get
through which is why we have so few
constitutional amendments but they can
be so important the most important
pieces in some ways of our government
that can bill of rights were amendments
and even during Lincoln's time he did
everything he could to get the Congress
to pass the 13th constitutional
amendment which would undo slavery and
then have it go out to the states and he
even tried to mobilize that as well but
it is important that there be no
roadblock if the people want to bring an
amendment whether it fails or succeeds
they should be able to do that and I
will look into what you're saying
because I don't know about that how did
Lincoln view the Constitution
well it's interesting some people say
that he had this dual feeling and he
revered the Constitution he revered the
framers I mean those people that grew up
in his generation remember they're not
that far from the founding interestingly
when he was a young man he gave this
famous speech called the Lyceum speech
where he worried that
his generation didn't have the same
challenges as the founding fathers that
they were the ones who disturbed spent a
state government and as a result they
were remembered in mountains and rivers
and streams and he thought there's
nothing left for our generation except
to protect what they've done modest
ambitions of course he never could have
imagined that the anti-slavery movement
in the 50s would lead to his becoming
president lead to a challenge in the
Civil War even greater perhaps than that
that faced the founding fathers but
because he revered the Constitution so
much that's why it was hard for him he
could not have been an abolitionist in
the 1850s because the abolitionist many
of them said tear up the Constitution if
it protects slavery as it does because
it protected the right of property in
each state then we don't care about the
Constitution he felt at that institution
were to be gone the Constitution the
whole framework that held the country
together would be gone but he really
loved the Declaration of Independence I
think he saw that and it's called for
equality as something that could in a
certain say Trump the Constitution one
of the few photographs during his
presidency one was this taken this is a
photograph I can't see it is this the
one that's the battlefield I was on the
battlefield when he won yes he went a
dozen times to visit the soldiers and
what would happen is that after each
battle was lost he felt compelled to go
and talk among the soldiers he would
ride his horse in their ranks he would
visit them in the hospital
somehow it buoyed their spirits and then
it buoyed his intern to see them and he
would come back then having their spirit
inside of himself and the amazing thing
was these trips as this one indicates to
the soldiers were so important to the
soldiers that when Lincoln ran again in
1864 against general McClellan who had
been so popular with the soldiers
earlier in the war he said that he cared
more about the soldiers vote than he did
even about winning the second election
if he could win the soldiers vote and
lose the second election he'd be fine if
he won the second election and lost my
soldiers vote he'd be devastated and the
amazing thing was some bond had occurred
between all these two these trips to the
front where the soldiers voted eight out
of ten for Lincoln even though they knew
that voting for Lincoln meant prolonging
the war since McClellan probably would
have brought about some compromise peace
maybe even losing their lives but they
had come to trust the cause and to trust
this man and that I think was was one of
his greatest gratifications of that
second election if you've just joined us
our conversation with Doris Kearns
Goodwin on
next call is from Stoneham Massachusetts
ah hi Doris hi
it's a pleasure to talk to have been so
excited about hearing your book and I
just noted it and I'm anxious to read it
thank you
first of all quickly do you know I may
need to do a Spielberg's new movie on
Lincoln oh I do indeed what is it what
is that going to be about you know well
sure I'll talk to you about it I mean
what happened is that I first met
Spielberg in 2000 when he was working on
a documentary on the Millennium and he
put together a bunch of historians and
he found out I was working on Lincoln
and he he said he would like someday to
make a movie on Lincoln and had known a
lot about Lincoln he thought about
Lincoln I think a lot of his life so he
early on optioned the rights to my book
before I even finished it and to
scriptwriters was put to work on it the
first one john logan who became a great
friend he wrote The Aviator and the
gladiator and I'm the Last Samurai and
then he put a second scriptwriter Paul
Webb who be he was a British playwright
who actually has become such a good
friend that he spent last Thanksgiving
and is coming this Thanksgiving with us
so I'm not sure when it will be made
hopefully sometime soon but I've trust
that there's no one's hands I would
rather have it in then Spielberg and
Liam Neeson has been chosen to play
Abraham Lincoln what what did Lincoln
sound like everybody says that he had a
thin high-pitched voice which you can't
quite imagine from that large character
but his voice they said could range very
Farkus in those days it was outdoor
venues essentially and somehow it could
be heard wherever it was there's one
reporter who heard him gave one of his
firm at first speeches the Peoria speech
in 1854 and wrote about it later and he
said when he first started out you're
aware of that then high-pitched voice
you're aware of how awkward he looks and
yet once he started speaking he spoke
with such conviction and with such
strength inside that suddenly his voice
became louder and his whole his whole
energy was seen in his face his face
would light up his body would move and
he became a different person so there's
no question that matching the dazzling
words that he was able to write his
voice was able to deliver them with
heartfelt feeling and that's the most
important thing about a speaker rather
than tenor of his voice and you
mentioned the movie that is still in the
planning stages
what will it be called oh I don't know I
suspect Lincoln
I mean what else would it be then
Lincoln I hope I don't know he'll he'll
decide that Seattle Washington you're
next yes this is Jim hi Jim I just want
to follow up on the the corporation's
enthroned citation earlier in the show
and give you give you what that citation
is now thank you that was in a letter to
Colonel William F Elkins and November 21
1864 and some of the surrounding
contexts that letter if I if I might
read it is we might congratulate
ourselves that this cruel war is nearing
its end it has a cost of vast amount of
pressure and blood and it's indeed a
trying hour for the Republic but I see
in the near future a crisis approaching
that unnerved me and causes me to
tremble for the safety of my country and
as a result of the war corporations have
been enthroned and an area of corruption
in high places will follow and the money
power of the country will endeavor to
prolong its reign by working upon the
prejudices of the people until all
wealth is aggregating a few hands and
the Republic is destroyed I feel at this
moment more anxiety for the safety of my
country than ever before even in the
midst of war god grant that my
suspicions may prove groundless and then
a few years later in January 1837
Lincoln said to this in a speech to the
Illinois legislature these capitalists
generally act harmoniously and in
concert please the people now they have
gotten into quarrel with himself we are
called upon to appropriate the people's
money to settle the quarrel so I just
wonder if you might say a few words on
you know Lincoln's relationship between
capitalists and his view of the
Commonwealth of the people thank you :
thanks for the follow well what he did
say at one point was that labor was
prior to capital I mean his whole theory
was that the laboring people built up a
work and a business possibly and then
they created a business that hired other
laboring people but without the laboring
man that everything was primary to that
and that capital was subservient to that
that's in a famous speech that he made
and so there's no question I think that
he would have a sense I mean he's
obviously in the age before the
Industrial Revolution before you've got
robber barons before you really got
full-scale capitalists they're just
beginning to have people
go to the cities and go from the farms
and begin to build up a certain amount
of wealth so it's interesting to wonder
what he would think if he were in a
later age and looked back on that desire
to see labor prior to capital how do you
live with Abraham Lincoln for ten years
so well I must say I could have gone on
another five years another ten years and
not ever lost interest in him you know
I'd wake up every morning and no I look
now at the place that I worked I I work
on this ridiculous chaise lounge in my
study upstairs because I need a laptop
and I need all my papers around me so I
can't work at a desk somehow so I'm
sitting sort of like I am right now with
the thing on my with a computer on my
lap I look now at that change lounge and
I feel fat when I go by it because I've
lost the focus of what it was like every
day to know because my husband works as
well as I said in the home he would go
to his study on one side of the house I
go to mine and we would read the
newspapers in the morning before working
and I'd have to somehow keep up with the
current day because I was doing analysis
for NBC at night so I'd at least imagine
I knew what was going on at least a
little bit and then we go into our
respective studies and then we'd
actually go into town in Concord to have
lunch everyday just to be able to get
out and then I'd read more of the
newspapers at lunchtime go back and work
in the afternoons do errands in the
afternoon and then every night we go to
the same restaurant in Concord this
place called sarafina's where there's a
group of 20 or 30 of us all of whom have
children who have grown and needs to sit
around in a public atmosphere at the bar
and become part of each other's lives
and it was something so structured about
those days with Lincoln at the core of
it that I miss it even now you know even
during the time of Monica Lewinsky or
the 2000 election or all the troubles
that we've been in 9/11 when I was
commenting them on television I knew I
could wake up the next morning with
Abraham Lincoln it was a great treat so
when you pick up the Boston Globe you go
to the front section of the sports page
I guess a sports page person we have a
deal that I get sports first and my
husband has the front page and then we
switch we're going to show our audience
your home in Concord Massachusetts we
traveled up there and preparing for this
interview and we will come back and
continue our discussion she spent OU's
book TV in depth with Doris Kearns
Goodwin
[Music]
I think my love of history goes back to
the days when I was only six years old
and my father taught me that mysterious
art of how to keep score at baseball
games so I could record for him the
history of that afternoon's Brooklyn
Dodger game and somehow when you're only
six years old and your father comes home
and spends two hours with you every
night listening to you record the
history even if it's just something that
happened that afternoon it makes it seem
there's something magic about history
and then I just had a great history
teacher in high school that made that a
deeper love and I came to a fascination
with the presidency because of having
worked with Lyndon Johnson when I was a
young girl so somehow the presidency and
the love of history melded together at
that point I like to wake up early in
the morning usually around 6:00 or 6:30
and go into my study and read over what
I had written the day before hoping that
it still looks good somehow went the
night before it always might seem great
and then the next morning oh this isn't
as good as I thought and then my husband
and I have breakfast and we both work he
works in another part of the house
because he's his writer as right he's a
writer as well as I am and then we
usually go out for lunch because we're
working here all day break at about one
o'clock until two o'clock and then do
some errands in the afternoon and come
back home maybe work another couple
hours and then there's a restaurant in
our town of Concord where about 20 or 30
people gather every night and we eat
around the bar and it's like a huge
family and then we come home after that
I may do some reading but not for
Lincoln just reading about some novels
or some mysteries go to bed relatively
early so I can get up again at 6 o'clock
when you ready what do you write as you
do your research well the first the
first couple years really required just
the research to get oriented and figure
out the angle you're going to take in my
case with Lincoln just having to read
all about the rivals the team of rivals
that I was going to be writing about
meant it was almost like an individual
biography on each one of them so that
was just pure research and that's fun
too because you're just learning the
whole time but then I remember reading
an essay by Barbara Tuchman who was a
great historian saying don't wait too
long to write because if you wait too
long you might get paralyzed so as soon
as I had a vague sense
where I wanted to go with this book
which took ten years altogether probably
in year two or one and a half I did
start writing and then would do more
research and more writing and more
research and then combine them
continually as I went along
this whole shelf over here is all
Lincoln books you know one of the great
things today about being able on the
Internet to get old books is you really
can get a collection of books that may
be out of print so it turns out that
there been more books written about
Lincoln than about almost any other
public figure and I was lucky enough by
going to use bookstores and Internet old
book sales to get an entire wall full of
Lincoln books and have them right here
at my side which was just terrific at
any one moment it's a Oh
Seward said that and be able to go to
Seward's diary or go to chases diary or
go to Stanton's private papers so
everything really was in this room of
the books that I needed and then the
rest were papers and primary sources
that I dragged into the house and
probably you know fifty cartons or so
that are stacked up in another room how
are you people you read oh well for me
because it takes me so long to write
these books I have to want to live with
the people side by side living with
Franklin and Eleanor Roosevelt for
example was such a great pleasure
because there was such large characters
and embarrassingly it took me six years
to write the book which meant longer
than world war two was fought so if
you're going to spend that many times
that much time with them if you're going
to live with them day by day you better
enjoy their company and so too with
Lincoln I mean I'd read an essay one
time by a great historian Ida Tarbell at
the turn of the century last century and
she said the reason so many people write
about Lincoln is because he's so
companionable and I truly felt that I
mean this book took me twice as long as
the Civil War took to be fought and yet
I enjoyed every day of living with this
man he was such a great figure such a
good man and his companionship I really
craved day by day I would have a hard
time writing about somebody that I
didn't want to live with day by day I
mean obviously great historians have
written about Hitler or Stalin I don't
think it could be me I need somebody
that I respect and admire even if they
have flaws I want to enjoy their company
day by day
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Doris Kearns Goodwin the book no
ordinary time you begin in Chapter one
relating the story of Franklin Roosevelt
as president remembering him as a young
boy in Hyde Park and how he would close
his eyes and reflect on that time what
was he thinking well what he was
thinking obviously was here he was as
president paralyzed from the waist down
unable to walk on his own power ever
again
since the polio had taken him in his
thirties he'd been such an athletic
outgoing person before that in terms of
his physical activity so before he go to
sleep at night he later said he'd like
to remember the days when he was a young
boy again at Hyde Park and it was a big
sledding hill behind his house and he
would as a boy go to the top of the hill
fly down that hill on his sled and then
take his sled and walk back up to the
top so somehow instead of counting sheep
he would remember in his mind going up
to the top of the sledding hill going
down going back up again and that
somehow allowed him to come and go to
sleep but what a sad thing that what
gave him that solace was the memory of
the time when he as a young boy had all
of his powers which were now no longer
allowed to him who was Missy lehand
Missy lehand was his secretary she had
started working for him when she was
about 18 years old and she and many ways
loved him the rest of her life she
became a secretary during the early days
she was with him in the 1920s when he
was down trying in Warm Springs and in
Florida trying to get his power to walk
again while Eleanor remained at home and
she stayed with him all through the
presidency and sadly had a stroke in the
middle of his White House years in the
last year's during the war and then went
home to Somerville and that's one of the
sad pieces of his life because I felt
sad that he didn't keep up with her when
she had the stroke and it was one of
those moments when you want to say
Franklin you I love you he's such a
great guy but you're not being good to
this woman he couldn't bear the hurt of
hauling her on the phone and knowing
that she couldn't talk back to him but
he should have at least talked to her as
if she were listening if she could
respond one of the I guess the sense you
get from from the book note nor near
times that he needed to be around people
the white house on the second floor was
a constant buzz of activity in people
and cards and social activity that he
was very outgoing no question I mean I
think what happened is in part because
he couldn't travel a lot inside
Washington he wanted the people around
him at every moment and he loved to talk
and he loved listening to stories and
loved telling stories so he made that
second floor of the White House into
almost the most exclusive residential
hotel you can possibly imagine Missy
lehand is living with the family
Churchill comes and spends weeks at a
time in a bedroom diagonally across from
Roosevelt Harry Hopkins who's his
foreign policy adviser is coming to
dinner one night early in the war sleeps
over never leaves until the war comes to
an end
Princess Martha who is in exile in
America during the war stays up there
with the family on the weekends and
Eleanor of course is there as well and
Eleanor's great friend Lorena Hickok a
former reporter who loved Eleanor is
staying next Eleanor so I kept imagining
what kind of conversations all these
people must have had in their bathrobes
at night as they gathered in the quarter
that surrounds those bedroom suites and
wished them when I've been up there with
Lyndon Johnson I thought of asking where
did Eleanor sleep where was Franklin
where was Churchill but of course I
wasn't thinking in those terms at 25
years old so I happened to mention this
on a radio program in Washington after
my book on Roosevelt came out and it
happened that Hillary Clinton was
listening so she promptly called me up
to the radio station inviting me to
sleep overnight the White House she said
we could then wander the Carter together
and figure out where everyone had slept
50 years earlier so two weeks later she
followed up with an invitation to a
state dinner between midnight and 2:00
a.m. after the dinner my husband and I
and mr. mrs. Clinton with my map in hand
went through every room yes Chelsea is
sleeping where Harry Hopkins once was
the Clintons where FDR was and we were
sleeping in Winston Churchill's bedroom
there was no way I could sleep I was
sure he was sitting in the corner
drinking his brandy and smoking his
ever-present cigar it was so exciting
why did he marry Eleanor I think he
loved
Eleanor when he met her and there was
probably no one like her I mean it was
to his credit that he could have had any
woman at the time he was very handsome
he was wealthy he was an aristocrat and
yet he saw an Eleanor something that he
hadn't seen in most of the bells that he
would have gone to the debutante balls
with she had gone she had such a sad
childhood her father and alcoholic her
mother dying her mother so beautiful
that she used to make Elinor feel that
Elinor had failed her mother because she
did not have a pretty face but then
Elinor was sent to a boarding school in
England and the head of the boarding
school made her feel that she should
have a commitment to social life not
society life but to Social Work that was
different from most women her age to not
just simply go back and be a debutante
so she started to work in a social house
to help people in poverty and so when he
met her he knew here was the young woman
who was interested in politics and the
poor in the things that he cared about
eventually in his life and I think he
chose the best woman for him I'm going
to read the letter that you found from
Lucy Rutherford to Anna Roosevelt but
before I do describe the relationship
between Franklin Roosevelt's daughter
and Lucy Rutherford well what happened
first of all to get back to who Lucy
Rutherford is is that when Eleanor and
Franklin were married about 12 years or
so she brought in a secretary Eleanor
did to help her name's Lucy Rutherford
at the time Lucy Mercer a beautiful
young woman a klasky woman actually and
it seemed that Franklin fell for her at
that time Eleanor was not very confident
in her marriage she had her
mother-in-law to contend with a very
powerful figure Sarah Roosevelt who had
taken control really of the kids and of
the family and she had lost a lot of her
best that she'd had when she was a young
working girl in the settlement house and
so anyway Franklin seemed to have fallen
for Lucy and Eleanor eventually
discovered some letters that he had
written to Lucy and Lucy had written him
offered him a divorce in 1918 but it was
the last thing he wanted and so
obviously agreed to get together and
stay together and he promised never to
see Lucy again but then when he didn't
he did keep that promise for a long
number of years but during the White
House years
Eleanor travelled she was the great
Eleanor Roosevelt so she wasn't home a
lot and he got very lonely especially
that last year of his life when his
health was failing and he had congestive
heart failure and he happened to run
into Lucy again and decided that he
wanted to see her again and just have
her come and talk to him in the White
House but the only way that he could do
that would be to have his daughter Anna
who was working as his hostess in the
White House when Eleanor was away
arrange for those meetings and Anna knew
in doing so that it would be hard if her
mother ever found out but on the other
hand she realized that her father needed
this companionship and so she did
arrange for Lucy to visit the White
House
from that last year all might have gone
with no one being hurt but for the
unfortunate fact that Lucy happened to
be at Warm Springs Georgia when he died
so that soon as Ellis she left
immediately of course but as soon as
Eleanor came down she would ask as you
would in a time of death tell me
everything that happened in the last day
or so and they told her that Lucy had
been there and it's hard to imagine how
she absorbed that news even as she had
to absorb her husband's death but
luckily in that day and age there were
no Press following it up she didn't have
to be humiliated in front of the country
she just had to assume it within herself
and when she found out not only that
Lucy had been there but that her
daughter Anna had been the one to make
those visits possible she must have felt
she lost her daughter and her husband at
the same time but I was so sad when I
heard that and didn't want to end the
book that way and was so delighted to
find that eventually she did she was
able to forgive at it and the mother and
daughter became close once again
let me read the letter that you include
page 631 of the paperback edition this
is from Lucy rutherford quote i had not
written before for many reasons but you
were constantly in my thoughts and with
very loving and heart torn sympathy and
I was following every step of the way he
told me so often referring to Franklin
Roosevelt and with such feeling of all
that you'd meant of joy and comfort on
that trip to Yalta I loved to think of
his very great pride in you Anna he told
me so often and with such feeling of all
that you had meant my love to you Anna
darling because you are his child and
because you are yourself
I am very devoutly and with hope
heartbroken sympathy Lucy Rutherford can
you imagine what that letter meant to
Anna who was feeling the guiltiness of
having arranged for these meetings
knowing that had hurt her mother but
then knowing that her father whom she
adored had talked in such loving terms
about her to Lucy and as I say luckily
what happened is that after a while
Eleanor just came to realize how much
Franklin had meant to her into the
country and that their partnership had
given her a stage that she never would
have had and everywhere she went after
he died people would tell her how much
they loved her husband conductors
cleaners people in all walks of life and
I think she was able then to reach back
beyond the hurt of knowing that he had
seen will see in those last years
remember all the good years that they
had had together and
the last years of her life she just put
this out of her mind whenever she talked
to Franklin I'm not sure she put it out
of her mind but she put it out of her
public conversation whenever she talked
of her husband it was only with love and
respect and it's a wonderful lesson in a
way to be able finally - maybe not
forget but to forgive something that it
hurts you in the past one of the
photographs a very thin and frail
Franklin Roosevelt in 1944 why did he
run for a fourth term well I think he
believed still that even though his
health was not what it had been before
and I'm not sure he was fully aware of
how sick he was he was somewhat such an
optimist but even though the doctors
told him that he had congestive heart
failure
I suspect that part of him thought I'll
beat this thing I beat polio so I could
beat this but I think he believed that
even without his full health that since
he was in the middle of the war he had
seen it up to that point he wanted to
see it through my guess is and sometimes
people have talked about the possibility
that had he had he not died when he did
he still might have turned the
presidency over at some point if his
health had gotten worse
once the war came to an end but he
wanted to see the war that had begun
under his term and under his term did he
like Harry Truman he didn't know Harry
Truman very well I mean it's one of
those weird things that this man who
become so important in our history
chosen as vice president without a lot
of forethought on his mind and I think
it's not to Roosevelt's credit that he
didn't spend a lot of time figuring out
who his vice president should be or
incorporating him into the
decision-making process especially when
he was so ill but I suspect it was part
of Roosevelt's denial that he was ill
not to want to think about this guy
who's going to replace him we were just
very lucky as a country that Harry
Truman was Harry Truman and became such
a great president our next call Highland
Beach Florida go ahead please
yes um a great fan of viewer thank you
and I had a question regarding Lincoln
in connection to all the presidents
you're talking about and the fact that
at some point in the critical times in
American history presidents have made
decisions and followed policies that
will that had to be kind of camouflaged
in a way in order to be accepted by the
people in the Congress and Lincoln's
case as you said earlier he was fighting
a war to preserve
the democratic experiment but he framed
it as a war to preserve the Union
something people to get their their
minds around and in in Roosevelt's case
of the way he packaged lend-lease and
other policies to help England before he
could get the rest of the country to
follow him into engaging in the war as
he wanted to you know long before Pearl
Harbor and right down to what they say
today about weapons of mass destruction
in Iraq and whether that was really just
a justification for responding to the
9/11 attack in it in a dramatic enough
way that sent a message to the world
saying that you know if you hit us as
hard and as drastically as we were there
will be just as hard and drastic
retaliation for lack of a better word
although I guess that's what it is and
our presidents justified in in kind of
covering again covering up might not be
the best word but you know using causes
an idea that people can relate to to get
their policies which they believe in to
be right under way thank you it's a very
thoughtful way of putting it and I guess
it depends on what the overall purpose
is that their policy is suggesting as to
whether or not it really does move with
a grain of history whether it will
create greater peace in the world
whether it creates greater justice in
the world you're right in talking about
Roosevelt that even in the early days
before Pearl Harbor he would talk about
lend-lease as a way of preventing us
from having to get in the war that if we
could aid Britain that somehow then
Britain would hold out against Germany
and it might make it easier for us not
to be in the war even though at some
level I suspect he knew that we were
going to have to get in that war
now could you say that that's deceptive
I think what he understood was that as
backed way back in 1938 he had given a
speech about quarantine eing the
dictators and it created such an uproar
in Congress calls for his impeachment
that he was going to try and entangle us
in what was going on in Europe that he
said it's a terrible thing to be the
president and democracy you feel like
you're leading a parade and you look
over your shoulders and nobody's
following
so he realized you had to move step by
step to educate and shape public opinion
to where you want them to go and in that
case getting America involved in my
judgement in world war two was essential
if Hitler had been allowed to succeed in
that war entire Western civilization
would have been destroyed so you do what
you can to bring the people along and
the goal was absolutely worth it he did
do a peacetime draft he did lend-lease
he on the ships and I think in some ways
his greatest leadership was even before
Pearl Harbor because it meant we were
more prepared when Pearl Harbor finally
happened and I think similarly with
Lincoln's he had to move step by step
toward that Emancipation Proclamation he
knew that if he had done it six months
earlier he later said he would have lost
the border states if he had done it
later he would have lost the morale
boost that it came it's one of those
mystical things about a leader that they
understand where the people are and how
to move them step by step so I think
ultimately the question will be was the
war in Iraq truly the right battle in
the war on terror or did it become a
diversion from the war on terror did it
use up our resources and our treasures
did it use up the lives for a larger
purpose and that's still what history or
did it do what they were hoping
eventually if it turned out to become a
strengthened hold and democracy or as
you suggest to show other people that
you better not mess with us so we'll
retaliate and history still is very
unclear about which way that's going to
turn out but that will be the judge of
whether or not that early talking about
in a different way
is justified or not if the end result is
not right if the war turns out to be a
diversion if it hurts the war on terror
effort then I think that the deception
at the beginning will be even more
difficult to accept we're getting a lot
of emails let me share a few with you
Neal Schaffer of Milwaukee says do you
think that Lincoln would have been as
revered as he is now had he not been
assassinated well there's probably no
question that dying at the height of the
war just about to be won and not having
to deal with reconstruction and all the
messy problems of peace probably did
keep his reputation intact in a way that
it wouldn't have been had he had to deal
with it
even saying that however I would so much
rather have had him and I think the
country would have been so much better
off dealing with reconstruction than
Andrew Johnson even if it meant that his
reputation was somewhat diminished
because it was complicated and messy to
have him with that much greater sense of
empathy I think toward the south but at
the same time
the rights of black Americans if we had
had a better reconstruction and what
followed it had not been as deadly
maybe the whole country would be better
off still today and then it would be
worth it to have some people say no he
wasn't good with reconstruction he was
great with war I'd still have that the
students from Bishop Kelly High School
in Tulsa Oklahoma they're all watching
one of the students Katie got well says
do you think it was a wise decision for
Lincoln to choose a southern Democrat
Andrew Johnson well I think at the time
he thought it was a wise decision
because it meant that he was binding up
this party that would come after the war
he needed to have Democrats and
Republicans together in a kind of union
party and Andrew Johnson had been a
supporter of the war he had been a good
military governor as it turned out
however he didn't know enough about
Andrew Johnson's character and the
weakness and the kind of leader he would
become it became somewhat evident on the
inauguration day that second inaugural
because he had had too much to drink he
hadn't been well and he gave this
incredible rambling speech that
everybody was panicked that would
suggest that he was not going to be up
to the job so I think had he known
Andrew Johnson better he might not have
been chosen actually the president in
those days didn't have as much to say
about who the vice president would be
the convention decided that more than he
but I think at the time he was pleased
to have that connection with a southern
Democrat as far as his being a northern
Republican it did not turn out very well
another one of those students DeMarre
Thompson says how did women influence
Lincoln's presidency how did women
influence Lincoln's presidency well
obviously in some ways the sad
relationship that developed with his
wife influenced the loneliness that he
felt during the presidency when his
little 10 year old son Willie died in
February of 1862 Mary was forever
altered and she took to her bed and
really couldn't even be a mother to
their youngest son tad who was 8 at the
time Willie had been almost like the
little Lincoln he could write poetry he
was sensitive he took care of his
younger brother who could had a speech
defect and most people couldn't
understand what he was saying and when
Willie died these diseases would spread
through the Capitol typhoid from the bad
drinking water because the soldiers were
using the river as a latrine
it killed Willie and in many ways had
killed Mary and so I think it's some
ways allowed Lincoln to feel however the
personal loss of the war and maybe to
project that even more to the people at
large when he talked about the
family circles that were also broken
because a soldier was lost that empathy
that was a remarkable part of his own
temperament was probably strengthened by
this loving kid and having this little
kid died in the middle of the war
another email from Ken Gleason who says
I think you're too willing to give
credit to your history teachers I'm a
college history teacher and you should
give more credit to your enormous energy
intensity interest in talent and says
aren't you the red-haired girl in the
spring of 1955 talking to myself and
others as we waited to go into the
entrance exam at Saint Agnes Catholic
High School in Russells oh wow that is
exactly where I went to Catholic school
I mean I went to public school actually
but would go to CCD on Wednesdays and
Sundays and got my confirmation in 1955
that is true when was this picture taken
oh this was at spring training I would
go down to spring training when my boys
were little just to be able to write
some sort of an article and be able to
play around and see the players in such
relaxed settings this is Wade Boggs and
I actually wrote an article on him one
year about his quest for the batting
title and it turned out to be an
extraordinary story because what
happened is I got very close to his
sister he was very close to his mother
and his sister and his family and his
sister had multiple sclerosis and she
was a big history buff so after I'd
written the article she came to
conquered my hometown to see the
historic sights in Concord and I took
her around and we became friends as a
result of it and then one day in 1986 it
would have been on the year that the Red
Sox almost won the World Series she
called me one day and we were talking
and I mentioned that Wade Boggs had had
a broken rib and we were afraid the
doctors and typical baseball fans we
didn't think the doctor was taking good
care of him I said he's got to get to
another doctor so it turned out that his
sister called the mother to say maybe he
should go to a different doctor and
sadly what happened is then the mother
called Wade Boggs and told her and he
told her that he loved her she went out
minutes later and was killed in a car
crash with her mother in turn so his
grandmother and his mother were gone and
for days he just went home he was so
close to the family and no one knew when
he'd come back to the Red Sox and in
that period of time I got a call from
him it was just astonishing he just
wanted to thank me that because of my
call to the sister and the sister scroll
to the mother and the mothers called to
him
he'd had a chance to tell her he loved
her right before she died so what
started out is just this you know
frivolous kind of baseball article about
Wade Boggs turned out to mean something
more to both of us and these are the
boys these are the boys that's when they
were little Richard on the Left was now
in his 30s and then Joey is in my lap
and Michael is to the right marek 27 or
28 our next call comes to us from Los
Angeles uh yes uh I first off as a
comment uh relative to what the caller
from Florida had said the Iraq war it
does seem that you know Sevigny
Brzezinski is not a particularly a big
fan of democracy and he's the guy who
mapped out this strategy in 1996 with
the grand chessboard I think he's what
he calls it and if if the people who
currently run this country are big
little D Democrats I would be quite
surprised otherwise they wouldn't have
been trying to overthrow Lugo Chavez for
three or four years and also having
overthrown and have been previously
destabilized jean-bertrand Aristide
andrey emplaced the tonton Macoutes
accessor z-- what I would say relative
to Lincoln is that I think these people
were currently running our country are
sort of coming out of that imperial
present presidency which he was the
first to really create through executive
order uh you know well it's sort of a
thing that's clung to by elements of the
far right I think there is some truth to
the notion that when the Congress
adjourns sin die by Robert's Rules of
Order
there's no lawful way that the president
can use emergency powers to reconvene it
thanks for the call no you are right
that what happened is after Fort Sumter
Congress was not set - it was not in
process right then I mean those days
Congress only sat for three or four
months because it was such a long time
to get there so Lincoln did have to take
executive actions and hope they would be
sustained when the Congress finally came
into being in July fourth of 1861 and
there is no question that war has
continually centralized power in the
executive it happened in the Civil War
it happened in World War one it happened
in World War two and it's happened in
recent years with foreign policy having
such a precedence so that we do have to
worry about that and I think one of the
things that so saddens me about the
history of the Iraqi war is that the
debate that took place in Congress
before Congress authorized the president
to take the actions that he did with
Saddam Hussein was so shortened I
remember Robert Byrd standing up and
saying this is a terrible that we are
not debating this the halls of the
Congress are silent and I think the
Democrats were to blame as well as the
Republicans it seemed to me remembering
back on that everybody was worried about
the midterm elections they wanted to get
this over and they were afraid I think
everybody of not standing up and looking
strong after September 11th but as a
result we went into that authorization
to the president without the Congress
really fully absorbing what the
information is they were getting if
we've had longer time if we had more
intelligence reports if we had forced
the administration to talk more to the
Congress
maybe that authorization would not have
taken place another email John Moore of
Lake Jackson Texas from your personal
experiences working closely with Lyndon
Johnson can you comment on Robert Caro's
biography volumes on his life and
political career I think Carol's
fantastic I mean he is a good a writer
as we'll ever get I think in history
writing his ability to render to life
like for example in that first volume
when he talks about electricity coming
to rural Texas I mean it's just magical
the way he makes it come alive for the
people living there and I think as he
keeps going along he's just understood
Lyndon Johnson Johnson may not have
liked some of the things he said about
him but Johnson would be a very proud I
think to know that a man of his stature
has spent his life working on him I
always have this fear someday that in
the afterlife there'll be a panel of all
the presidents that I've ever studied
and each one will be telling me what I
got wrong and the first person will be
Lyndon Johnson saying and how come that
damn book on the Kennedys was twice as
long as the book you wrote about me well
Robert Caro's books are three times as
long as anything I've written and
they're worth every word Chanhassen
Minnesota you're next franklin roosevelt
achieved so much such as social security
the sec the Federal Reserve Open Market
Committee the Fair Labor Standards Act
FDIC FHA unemployment insurance the GI
Bill temporary relief jobs get people to
the Great Depression but I've always
believed his best work was his
extraordinary leadership during will
- and my question is how or why was
Franklin Roosevelt so effective during
World War two in the country was so
unified especially when you compare that
to the quagmire and Vietnam or the
current mess in Iraq where it seems to
be going so badly well you know I think
what Roosevelt understood in World War
two was that if it were going to be a
long war which he suspected it was that
you had to involve as many people on the
homefront as possible so they would feel
connected to that war so in that regard
when he did first of all he had twelve
or thirteen million people working in
the factories during the war another
fourteen million were drafted and in the
Army during the war but then he also had
auxilary fire auxilary police he had
blood drives he had he had people buying
bonds even if it wasn't the most
efficient way to raise money for the war
because he wanted them to feel part of
the drive he had aluminum drive he had
scrap drop scrap rubber drives all of
which was designed to say that if we're
going to be fighting a war abroad
everybody at home should feel connected
to it I had often thought that after
September 11th that President Bush had
this incredible opportunity if he had
gone to the country and just as
roosevelt did roosevelt said when that
war happened dr. new deal now has to
become dr. win the war and it made some
of the Liberals mad because he decided
he had to have a partnership with
business if they were going to build the
tanks and the weapons and the planes
that were necessary for the war he gave
them great contracts he gave them and he
relaxed antitrust regulations they
became important to him even as he
protected labor at the same time if
President Bush had gone to the country
and said you know dr. tax cut now has to
become mr. 9/11 and used the resources
that the tax cut had provided possibly
to emergency situation to make it better
in our country it might have been ready
there for Katrina we could have had a
public health system that was
strengthened for the potential of
biological attack that would have been
good in its own right as well as helping
in case there were a biological attack
they could have been auxiliary fire it
could have been a Villere police there
could have been potentially a draft
again so that more people were felt to
be part of this effort instead of having
this small group of people that are in a
volunteer army all of that was possible
there was such unity after 9/11 and then
I think what history will have to
suggest Afghanistan seemed to have
produced and kept that unity was Iraq
the right battle to fight to keep that
unity alive so far that unity seems to
be breaking up
and with all that wellspring of support
one might have hoped that our home front
could have been mobilized in a somewhat
different way from no ordinary time can
you describe the relationship between
Sarah Roosevelt her son and Eleanor I
would not have wanted I think Sarah
Roosevelt as a mother-in-law if I were
Eleanor Roosevelt
she was very important to Franklin
however she gave him whatever that
confidence is that he had as a young boy
and then as a president and as an older
man came from that mother's undying love
her only child with her husband who was
a much older man and she doted on him
but so much so that I think sometimes it
was hard for him because when he was
young she took him out of school she
didn't let him go to Groton till he was
older than the other people and he never
got along easily with men of his own age
but nonetheless once he got married I
don't think she was ready to let him go
and as a result of that Eleanor had a
very hard time finding a relationship
with her husband she moved into a house
she created two houses in New York one
for her and one for them you know with a
corridor that went right in between when
Eleanor tried to discipline her children
somehow she would be the one who would
say no don't worry one of her kids did
something bad
Eleanor's child she then bought him a
car to make him feel better so I think
that she was a very difficult force in
Eleanor's life and made their marriage
much more complicated than would
otherwise have been even though she gave
him that fundamental confidence that a
mother gives a child how long did she
lose she died in the 40s so she was she
was pretty old she was a sturdy
character and her death I think was in
41 was very hard for him he wore a black
armband for a long period of time I mean
he really did love that woman so I've
got to give her enormous credit for that
Santa Rosa California for Doris Kearns
Goodwin you're next this is a rumor that
I've heard by the way great show thank
you very much about Lincoln and I don't
know if it's true maybe you found
something that might indicate such that
he might have been bisexual or gay and
also Eleanor have a lesbian relationship
Thanks well actually those two questions
do belong together in a certain way
because here's what I came away thinking
for as far as Lincoln goes people
assumed he might have been gay and
they've written about it recently for
two reasons one that he slept in the
same bed with his great friend Joshua
speed for three years and two that he
wrote flowery letters to speed
which ended with yours forever Lincoln
but in fact as I looked into that period
of time what I discovered is that men's
relationship with each other were very
intense they're more than it would be
now and women's likely were intense with
one another and sleeping in the same bed
was not anything unusual when Lincoln
was on the circuit in Illinois he
actually would sleep sometimes two or
three to a bed the only person who got
his own bed was the judge because he
weighed 300 pounds so he had his own bed
and then I discovered the letters
between the other people that I was
writing about for example when Seward
and chase were young men they had both
lost their wives this is before of
course they became Secretary of War and
Secretary of Treasury and here's what
Stanton writes in that suit and chase
chase and Stanton rather on Stanton
writes to chase and he says ever since
our our intercourse last summer no one
is in my mind more waking and sleeping I
dream of you at night and I want to hold
you by the hand and say I love you no
one suggested that Stanton was gay no
one suggested that Chase was gay when
Seward was in the state legislature an
older state senator became in law became
romantically involved they became
romantic I think without sex saying ever
since I think about you I feel woman ish
in my feelings about you no one
suggested that either one of them were
gay and in fact this older colleague of
Seward's eventually tried to make a pass
it to his wife and it almost broke up
through its marriage so I think if we
look back in the time we have to realize
that men had these close attachments
there was no definition then of what
homosexuality meant until I think 1868
but more importantly they felt free to
talk to you one another in this flowery
way that might seem odd to today's
modern world
similarly Eleanor wrote very flowery
letters to her friend Lorena Hickok and
women historians have written about the
19th century in the early 20th century
to say that was very common for women to
write that way to each other and I think
part of it is that women and men
couldn't have friendships the same way
they can today
everything was so structured and
chaperoned so men men and women women
became more intensely involved and I
would argue that it's probably the
context of the time that is more
important than to label them today from
our own perspective the question has
been answered by Thomas Lee on the
Wigwam in Chicago oh yay I can't believe
I forgot it already it was a longest
Chicago River at the intersection of
Lake and wacker it was built in 1860 and
torn down or destroyed in 1867
well thank him very much that's great
that's what's good about this show
Atlanta is next hello that's a good
questions and I'll hang up number one
what was the deal with general McClellan
for the supreme union commander he
certainly seemed very helpful to the
south then of course he ran against
Lincoln in 1864 was he a high-level
saboteur and number two how concerned
was Lincoln about the gathering strength
of the old colonial powers there were
English troops in Canada French troops
in Mexico was he concerned that the old
colonial powers wanted to try to move
back in carve up the North American
continent as they had in the previous
centuries thank you well on your second
question first yes he was very concerned
in fact England and France I think
viewed the Civil War as an opportunity
for them not only to come back and get
more land perhaps from America but even
more importantly they wanted the whole
democratic experiment to fail I mean
they're protecting monarchies they're
protecting a different form of
government so if it proved that ordinary
people could not govern themselves it
was good for them and especially the
aristocrats especially the wealthy
classes in England and France were the
ones who in many ways were supporting
the south in their struggle against the
north so it was very important and
Seward as his secretary of state played
yeoman work actually in keeping the
English people out of the war and
keeping the French out of the war the
masses in England the working men were
very in favor of the northern cause
because they were in favor of
emancipation but the ruling powers were
exactly as he suggested trying to
maneuver us into a situation where if
the north were to lose and if the south
split off then maybe they could pick off
Mexico pick off things could be done so
as far as your first question goes which
I forgot opens the first question are
you still there
he is not actually okay well I'll come
back to it when I remember I shouldn't
have answered the first okay but I was
looking at this email this is from Ray
West or Ray Anderson of West Virginia
saying that if Lincoln were to be
involved in politics today which party
would he aligned himself with well the
interesting thing
if Lincoln were involved today he was
very loyal politically took him a long
time to leave the Whigs
before he became a Republican so I think
he would stay with the Republican Party
but my guess is he would try to move it
in a progressive fashion so that it did
care about people who didn't have
educational opportunity didn't it did
care about people who were poor and was
able he once said that government was
there to do for individuals what they
could not do so well for themselves and
so I think he'd have a different
philosophy from the conservative
elements of the Republican Party but I
think he'd probably try and make the
Republican Party what he believed in
rather than to switch to some other
party and the color was asking about
general McClellan why did that go to
watch Dan brenigan liked it in 1864 well
to go back to the caller's argument
about what was general McClellan and was
he a saboteur now I remember the
question I mean I don't think it's fair
to say McClellan was a saboteur what
happened is that he was a conservative
Democrat he did not believe that
emancipation should be at all a goal in
the war and as a result he was very
upset when Lincoln introduced the
Emancipation Proclamation he thought it
would make the war longer it would give
more resistance to the south but more
importantly the trouble with him as a
general which Lincoln should have seen
earlier than he did was that he was
great at organizing the troops the
troops loved him he could discipline
them and we had no army to begin with so
he needed to do that
but he created a great engine as Lincoln
finally later said but it was a
stationary engine he somehow didn't have
whatever it took to take his troops into
war some people have argued that he
loved them so much he didn't want to
take them into battle some people have
argued that he really was going slow
because he wanted the war to come to an
end without hurting the south but
whatever it was he turned out not to be
a very good general no question and
Lincoln took too long to actually ask
for his resignation so then in 1864 in
the summer of 1864 it looked like the
fortunes of the war in a very low ebb
even though Gettysburg had been won in
Vicksburg Hedren won for the North
Lincoln wasn't sure that he was going to
win another election because the morale
was down the war was going on too long
so many lives had been lost
people were blaming him that the
Emancipation Proclamation had prolonged
the war so the Democratic convention
thought McClellan would be the perfect
person to run against him because he had
the support in the north of what were
called the conservative Democrats the
copperheads the people who thought the
war was going on too long and a
compromise peace would be a good thing
to happen
and I think he thought because he'd been
so popular with the army that he would
have the support of this huge element
that was in the army as it turned out
Lincoln won that army vote which
mattered so much to him and McClellan
handled the election terribly his his
letters to the people and the papers
were troubled troubled and he then went
off into the sunset and made money but
the trouble with McClellan was that he
wrote letters to his wife all during the
Civil War and the letters are so damning
to him that now that they've been
published I think that's hurt his whole
reputation for ever for history he talks
when he first gets in there that God has
placed him where he is that he could be
a dictator if he wanted to and he says
such terrible things about Lincoln and
Stanton he never takes responsibility
for any of his failures during the
Peninsula Campaign when he failed he
blamed it outright on Stanton to the
extent when Stanton in fact he wrote a
telegram in to the White House saying if
I lose this battle it will be your fault
and and you have sacrificed the army and
in fact the telegraph operator was so
stunned at the insubordination of that
last line that he cut it out so that
Lincoln and Stanton didn't see that it
became knowledgeable later but Lincoln
then after Stanton was getting pounded
by the newspapers after McClellan was
going everywhere saying the reason he
lost the Peninsula Campaign was that
Stanton had refused to reinforce him
when he had soldiers and he could have
spent to him Lincoln then gave a huge
speech to a union rally bigger than any
rally since the inauguration in which he
took the responsibility he said it's not
Stanton I had no soldiers to send him I
would have sent them if I could and
you're not to blame Stanton and it
finally stopped the critique of Stanton
but just the opposite of Lincoln who
acknowledged errors immediately who
shouldered responsibility for the
failures of his subordinates McClellan
was just the opposite always blaming
somebody else for what he did once a
month we spent three hours with a
distinguished author and this month
Doris Kearns Goodwin is our guest
another 45 minutes with more of your
phone calls
Paris California good morning my name is
Shira I'm coming from Paris California
this is because you have such a
wonderful compassion for writing history
any time in the future decline I'm
writing a book about civil rights you
know I don't know what I'm going to do
next and that is a good idea you know
one of the difficulties is that you get
so caught
in what you're doing that it's hard to
imagine leaving Lincoln right now but in
some ways civil rights movement would be
the logical outgrowth of the fact that
after Lincoln left the presidency it
still needed that civil rights movement
in the 1950s 1960s to complete the
emancipation and the true beginning of
the breakdown of segregation and to
beginning of equality for black
Americans so it might be a nice sequel
the hard thing is as I say even when I
had to move from Roosevelt to Lincoln
and I had to move all my Roosevelt books
out of my study I felt like somehow I
was betraying Roosevelt and so I think
it'll be a while before I can leave mr.
Lincoln behind but at some point soon
I'm sure I'll come up with something
else because I can't wait to be back in
the thick of another book again next
call Little Rock Arkansas go ahead
please call you with us yes I'm here
thank you good afternoon it's good when
I wanted to ask you to please opine on
the modern day phenom that high-tech
computerization has eliminated the need
of big government socialism that the
Democrats offered and what did they
possibly bring to the tables to assist
our free enterprise capitalist system
well you know I think what the Democrats
still stand for is the idea that
government can aid people in areas where
they cannot aid themselves which is what
Lincoln stood for so many years ago and
there's no question in my mind still
that Social Security is a fundamental
right that the Democrats are arguing to
protect that there is a need obviously
for free enterprise if it's truly free
to be there our system is built upon
that but in some cases that free
enterprise doesn't really become free
and you've got corporations that need to
have some sort of stimulus from the
government to make sure that they're not
undoing that freedom freedom that we
stand for and there's no question that
there's issues of health care and at
issues of job creation and issues of
poverty that I think the Democrats
traditionally have talked about now
whether or not they've been able to
reach the country today to argue that
those are the right values that we
should be fighting for as a country is
the question because they haven't won in
recent elections but the values that
underwrote the Democratic Party in my
argument in my mind in the 60s when the
civil rights
movement was there when Medicare was
first formed when aid to education came
through in order to use the government
to help people who might not have had
the chance to help themselves when
Social Security was updated and when the
civil rights laws were passed and
segregation and bring voting rights to
black Americans I think all of those are
things that our country is eventually
proud of and that was originally
initiated under democratic authority
even though Republicans and great
Republicans came by their side and I
look back you know some people look on
the 60s as a sad period because it ended
so badly with the anti-vietnam war
moving and the deaths of Bobby Kennedy
and Martin Luther King but in some ways
it was a time when people cared about
public issues and they were willing to
fight for those public issues and I look
back on that era with some nostalgia I
must say maybe it's because I was
younger than that's probably part of it
what did lend you what President
Johnson's feel how did he feel about
Martin Luther King's well I think at the
beginning there was some sense of
tension because Martin Luther King's a
leader any president feels here's a
leader and he's operating outside the
system of the government and was
pressing the government to move more
quickly than Johnson might have thought
he was able to move but the amazing
thing that happened I think was that
after the Civil Rights Act of 64 passed
ending segregation in the south and
Martin Luther King was obviously
instrumental in the creating the
movement that created the impetus to
create that act Johnson got such
enormous pleasure from knowing he had
done something that would stand the test
of time that he became a real civil
rights advocate and in 1965 after the
first act had passed his adviser said
don't go for voting rights the country
has to absorb that Civil Rights Act of
64 but he said this is my moment
it may not continue I'm going for it so
in his State of the Union address in 65
he called for a Voting Rights Act and
then of course Martin Luther King made
that come alive by his march from Selma
to Alabama in Montgomery and when he was
beaten up by the by the southern people
down there and the police force it made
the country feel a certain sense of
wanting to do something to make this
right and that's when Lyndon Johnson
called for a joint session of Congress
and gave the great speech called the we
shall overcome speech in fact I'm proud
to say my husband worked on that speech
and I was a graduate student at the time
and I remember being with my friends
feeling it was one of the great moments
in history to hear Lyndon Johnson
because what happened then was that he
and
middle of the speech he talked about
civil rights is not a black problem it's
not a white problem history and fate
have come together in one place in Selma
Alabama just as they did in Lexington
and Concord just as they did in a
thematics and then he took up the anthem
of the civil rights movement and said
and we shall overcome and for all of us
who have been involved in the civil
rights movement that was the anthem so
to hear the president no longer fighting
against the civil rights movement but
actually embracing it at that moment it
was a moment were the most emotional
moment of my young life I think is
Apollo in public life how did you meet
your husband well he came to Harvard
while I was teaching there to finish a
book and he had an office right near
mine and I of course know he was and he
claims he sort of knew about me because
he knew I had worked for Lyndon Johnson
and he asked me out to dinner and I must
say the first night I met him I knew
that this was the man I wanted to marry
but it took a while our next call comes
from Oakland California go ahead please
Oakland you with us I
I grew up in Brooklyn and went to st.
Paul's Catholic Church school rather the
nuns also love the Brooklyn da Janelle
Kenny we would all have to pray for them
to win the series that's great I have
two questions in 2001 President Bush
signed an executive order permanently
feeling off from the public all
presidential records going back to
Reagan now any requests for documents
relating to past presidencies have to be
approved by the White House will this
affect the work of historians like
yourself and secondly President Lincoln
was a brilliant president I believe he
wrote most of his own speeches but to
Lincoln depend on any one advisor to the
degree that President Bush depends on
Karl Rove you know I think as far as
your first question goes that in recent
years probably in the last 40 years even
there has been a tendency to hold back
presidential papers more and more and it
just seems to be escalating with each
year I remember even when we were
working on Johnson's memoirs a lot of
what was going to be used in the memoirs
was not going to be open later for the
people until years went by even the
tapes it's taken a while for them to be
transcribed and put into the public use
so it is true I think that historians
are going to be constructed
proscribed in what they do by this
tendency of presidents to be closing off
records I mean eventually they'll be
opened up but by that time the immediacy
of the event and the understanding of
the context might be lessened so it
probably will make it harder I think for
historians to get that full job and I
think that I don't know I mean I think
in some ways you know even more
problematic for people will be that idea
that letters as we talked about earlier
are not being written diaries are not
being kept in the middle of the White
House because people are afraid they
might be subpoenaed at a certain point
so you're not going to have that
intimate record that people had in later
times Sam and Laurie Smith of Longwood
Florida email did you have any ongoing
interactions with the first lady
ladybird Johnson and what kind of
relationship did you have in putting the
book together well I got to know her in
those last year's when when I was going
down to the ranch because I actually
stayed at the ranch and I must say that
she is one of the classiest women I've
ever known
she she loved that man she protected him
she went about her own work she was
working on her own memoir at that time
and she welcomed I'd like to believe my
coming down there to be with him because
it was almost like I could be a camp
counselor Lyndon Johnson needed somebody
at his side every moment so when I was
there I'd like to believe she felt she
was free to go shopping or going to
Austin or do something because I could
keep him company but without her I think
the stability that she provided I don't
think he ever would have become what he
did she was so different from him so and
that M pathetic so compassionate in a
human beings when he would yell at
somebody she would never do that she
could ease things over for that person
that he might have hurt and he loved her
there's no question about that did you
ever get the Johnson treatment not
really I mean interestingly I think
maybe because I saw him do that other
people and it's one thing it's not
easily able to forgive I don't think you
could ever yell at somebody in public in
any good way and humiliate them what was
what I used to hear he did when he did
this in the White House he'd feel so bad
the next day then maybe a car would
arrive at that person's home is a make
up because I didn't mean to yell at you
but he never really he would tease me
you know he would call me a lefty and he
would call me a pinko and he would think
that I was part of that younger
generation that didn't understand why
the war in Vietnam had to be fought but
never with a mean-spiritedness and I
suspect it was because it was later in
his
I've had I known him at the height of
his power I'm sure he never would have
talked to me as openly as he did or
never would have spent so much time with
me obviously wouldn't had time but in
those last year's he was lonely and I
happened to be there Levittown Rhode
Island you're next I like to ask you a
question and then I'd like to respond to
your answer through the 30 the the
Liberty League which was the leaders
over the Capitals world in this country
tried to finance a overthrow the
Roosevelt administration tried to
convince General Smedley Butler become a
dictator in this country the same
Koufax's of financing the hitler war
machine in germany for the purpose of
defeating the Communists and the
Communists eventually saved capitalism
from the fascists will be created I like
your point of view on this and I'd also
like to respond to your answer Thank You
Colin sure I mean you are right that
things were so confused at that time we
now look on communism as a negative
force in the world but there's no
question but that in World War 2 you
know without Russia without the
Communist ability to join in the Allied
cause after Hitler had tried to defeat
Russia and then Russia came back on our
side that things would have been very
different and I think fascism would have
had a much greater chance of existing
and there were fights in Europe between
Communists and fascists there were
fights here between Communists and
fascists and I think the world was in
much better came up so much better off
at least when fascism was destroyed and
then if only communism had stuck to some
of that earlier ideology that was part
of Marx which had to do with labor and
it's prior to capital just as Lincoln
had talked about much earlier and not
gotten into the loss of civil liberties
and the kind of top-heavy government it
did there was something ideologically
that they were right about at the
beginning but it went awry I think with
Stalin collar we want to move on other
calls but a quick follow-up what I like
to say is the fact that the Russians are
saved us from the fascists but we
created we created Hitler and Mussolini
DuPont at controlling interest of
general mode
it was with the building tanks and
armored cars in Nazi Germany during the
thirties thanks for the call San Diego
you're next yes hi
Thank You c-span for putting this on I
really appreciate this opportunity I
think I spent more time trying to get
through to you guys than I have trying
to get through to a rock concert in my
year Wow
I'm miss Goodwin thank you for taking my
call I've been working on a documentary
about an event that occurred in Los
Angeles specifically June 23rd 1967
President Johnson had come to Los
Angeles to kick off his Democratic
fundraiser for his reelection campaign
and I've been working on this for about
four years so you're really an
inspiration to me in the way that you
stick with a story for so long it you
really imbibe the person my question to
you is do you have any event this was
known as the Century Plaza protests also
known as by some is bloody Friday I was
happen to be a 10 month old baby at this
event and there was a picture published
of me in the Free Press of what seemed
to be police batons coming over my baby
carriage of my mom fending them off I
know specifically through some White
House documents that one of these were
sent off to the White House because the
president's statement was that he didn't
see the civil unrest occurring outside
the Century Plaza Hotel so I was
wondering if you have any personal
knowledge of this event and/or what's
your opinion on the effect of the
anti-war movement demonstrations and
Johnson's decision not to run again in
March of 68 Thank You caller yeah I
don't know specifically about that event
but there's no question that you're
right that those anti-war demonstrations
were increasing increasing and
increasing in 67 and 68 and I think
Johnson felt unable to go around the
country in any free way and he was
really limited to a certain extent to
going to army camps when he gave
speeches and not being able to be as
free as he was before then and I'm sure
that that contributed to his feeling
that if he were going to run again
68 and go around the country campaigning
it would be a very difficult it was so
hard for him to see those signs hey hey
LBJ how many kids did you kill today the
movement had grown in intensity and he
knew that he had lost a large part of
the American people and that's partly
what I think made him withdraw from that
race I mean it's always said that when
Walter Cronkite turned against the war
as he seemed to saying it was a
stalemate after the Tet Offensive that
Johnson said he had lost middle America
but even before that in 67 as you
suggest and it earlier in 68 he had seen
those massive demonstrations and he must
have known that it would impede any
chance he had to go around the country
he had so loved the campaign in 64 his
energy was just phenomenal he would stay
up until 3:00 a.m.
even if there were just three people
left in a crowd and he couldn't get that
energy back from the crowd because he
wasn't going to be able to go around the
country again so I think there's note
the anti-war movement and its strength
not only because it produced McCarthy
and it produced the primary and it
produced Bobby Kennedy and he didn't
want to run against bobby kennedy the
very fact that those demonstrations were
taking place hampering him had something
to do with his withdrawing from the race
so it was important Franklin go north
Burke Illinois says that a recent
segment on Meet the Press left a
distinct impression that Lyndon Johnson
named Ramsey Clark as Attorney General
specifically to get his father Tom Clark
to resign his position on the Supreme
Court in order to nominate Thurgood
Marshall that was an amazing tape when I
heard that on Meet the Press I hadn't
known that tape before but what you hear
is Lyndon Johnson talking to Tom Clark
and to Ramsey Clark and he wants to put
Ramsey Clark on the court but most
importantly he wants to get Tom Clark
off and once what Ramsey Clark into the
cabinet but he most importantly wants to
get Tom Clark off there so we can point
the first black American to the court so
he's saying to Tom you know in Ramsey
I'd like to get you into this Attorney
General's job but it can't really quite
happen if you fought us on the court
because it'll be some sort of a conflict
of interest in Randy's well I'm not so
sure it's a conflict of visions and
Johnson oh I think it is I think it is
next thing you know of course Ramsey
talks to his father Tom Clark Tom Clark
decides that he's going to retire from
the court even though he wasn't that old
to give his son a chance so in one of
those ways that Lyndon is playing three
different people for a goal that's a
good goal to put Marshall on the court
you are quoted as saying in reference to
LBJ that I think some people who go into
public life
if they go in needing the applause of
thousands they're never going to work
out successful in the end because they
don't know who they are apart from the
crowds you know it did seem that Johnson
had this enormous hole inside that
needed to be filled by the applause of
the people and you know in a system like
ours where everybody goes up and down in
reputation even the best presidents go
through really tough eras if that's
what's holding you up it's going to not
sustain you that's why there was the
difference between Lincoln and my
argument who wanted the office and the
power for accomplishing something that
would stand the test of time so if if
the people turned against him or he
failed in a certain sense he could be
could be driven by that larger goal now
Johnson eventually when he became
president did have larger goals in mind
and I think he became a stronger person
but up until that time he seemed to be
the kind of person who just needed to
have that support from the people to
fill up some need inside that wasn't
quite there Springfield Illinois
go ahead hi thank you for taking my call
howhow are you able in writing your book
on Lincoln to stay on your topic when
there are so many other interesting
little tidbits that you didn't find
yourself going off on tangents and then
are you going to be coming in doing a
book signing here I am I'm coming i
think february 12 to springfield to
speak at the library i can't wait to see
the new library i was there at the
groundbreaking with david Donald and so
I saw it in its very early stages but I
can't wait to see the finished product
it sounds amazing you know it is true
you do get off on tangents and you get
involved with everybody's life and you
just have to make sure that you don't
let the narrative be destroyed as a
result for example Seward had a daughter
named Fanny and when she was 16 she
wanted to be a writer so she started to
keep a diary and her diary is wonderful
I mean it's just that the young girl's
diary she keeps it until she's 21 years
old
and then she dies at 21 she didn't even
think she wanted to get married because
she thought you couldn't have a career
as a writer and be married so all of her
life force is poured into this diary I
became so interested in this little girl
Fanny I became so interested in her
mother Francis and they're important to
my story but not as important as I
almost was going to make them I mean I
would sometimes go half a chapter
on one or the other and then you finally
have to decide you have to cut back
similarly Kate chase Chase's daughter
and she was such an interesting sad
creature who was the most beautiful
woman of her age
everybody courting her and she marries
this wealthy man just in order to help
her father's ambitions and I found the
love letters between her and her husband
and he turned out to be an alcoholic and
to abuse her and I found those letters
as well of hers later in life and all of
that was in passed the part of my book
so it's like one paragraph in the
epilogue but you do keep involving
yourself in all the people and the key
as a narrative historian you have to
decide when to introduce them and when
to cut them out and just say some other
day I might write about these people or
I can talk about them to my friends but
if I put their full stories in here the
book will not only be 700 pages of text
it'll be 12,000 and no one will be able
to pick it up Jack Witten had emailed
and there's a photograph of the scene in
your book he said that I heard a number
of accounts on what secretary Stanton
said when Lincoln passed away one said
now he belongs to the Angels 24 hours it
was reported that he said now he belongs
to the ages yes that is true I mean
there are about four or five different
accounts some say he now belongs to the
Angels he now belongs but now he belongs
to the ages and it's one of those
moments just as that picture that you're
showing where a lot of people were there
that night after he was assassinated
they carried him to this Petersen house
across the street and the members of his
cabinet came some of his friends came as
secretaries came but at the end more
people claimed they were there than
actually were there it's one of those
moments where everybody wants to be at a
big event and they were teasing that the
room could not possibly have kept all
those people together so you can quite
imagine that whatever was said that
night gets reported in a newspaper and
then it goes down through the ages and
no one's exactly clear but the words
that we now remember as Stanton's words
are now he belongs to the ages which is
a wonderful tribute especially given
Lincoln's desire to be remembered after
he died or Doris Kearns Goodwin Tucson
Arizona next caller go ahead hi my name
is Ruth calling from Tucson and my first
introduction to you was through the Ken
Burns baseball series and which made me
a great day out of you anyway
I was just wondering what was your
impression of that project and the
working with mr. Byrne
Oh burns is such a passionate
enthusiastic character that he makes all
of the things he do comes alive I think
what happened is he came to see me
because he knew that he was going to be
making the Brooklyn Dodgers and the Red
Sox big parts of his series on baseball
given such underdogs they were and so
much passion and so much drama around
them and he knew that I had been both
fans of the Brooklyn Dodgers originally
and then the Red Sox but I had no idea
when he came we talked for maybe like an
hour an hour and a half and you think
you're going to be on there for like a
half a minute or two minutes so I told
him everything about old boyfriends that
I'd like to I gave up because they
didn't like baseball even mentioning one
of these boyfriends and somehow all
these things were put on the air but it
was a wonderful experience in fact the
interesting thing is I my book on
Roosevelt came out the same year that
his documentary on baseball came out and
so everywhere I went to talk about
Roosevelt people would ask me about
baseball because they'd seen his
documentary and it was really that
response of people a lot of women coming
up to me and say we had a similar
relationship with our father we loved
baseball as well he taught me how to
keep score and people would talk about
their memories of growing up in the 50s
in a similar town to the one that I'd
grown up in and that's really what
prompted me I never would have written a
memoir the idea of writing a memoir I
seemed ridiculous for me because I
wasn't a big public figure but I decided
to write about growing up in love with
the Dodgers because of Ken Burns
documentary and it gave me so much more
pleasure than I could possibly have
imagined to recreate that time in my
life and the weird thing is I think
anyone that grew up in the 50s in a
suburb there was something almost
Universal about our lives you know
jumping rope being out on the street you
know having a bicycle we could have a
kickstand and you didn't have to have a
lock on it loving baseball as passionate
as we did the McCarthy era and what that
meant and the early civil rights era
that it turned out that the memoir
struck a chord I think not because it
was my story but because it turned out
to be a lot of other stories as well and
that all is owed to Ken Burns I never
would have done it without him by the
way who was the edits in edits field
some guy named Charlie Ebbets so he's
gone down in history forever even though
a bit field is finally gone but I think
the park was built in a way back in like
1912 so it was one of the smallest and
most intimate and most wonderful parks
that ever existed New York City
you're next my question is for mrs.
Goodwin about the contrast between
Lincoln who had very little formal
education certainly no wealth or
privilege in his background who wrote
incredibly beautiful speeches and
letters many of which have been quoted
this afternoon and the current chief
executive who comes from a background of
wealth and privilege private school Yale
University who seems unable even to
write a simple sentence uh this seems to
be a trend in politics today we don't
have any great speakers or writers I'm
just curious about that thank you well
you know one of the things that so
struck me about Lincoln's early
education compared to educational system
today is that he didn't have a width of
education but he was so deep in the
things that he read I mean for example
as a young child he had to scour the
countryside for books and lay everything
he could lay his hands on he would read
but they were some of the best
literature in our history he read
Shakespeare he read Aesop's fables he
read the King James Bible he read poetry
and so these Cadence's I think got into
his soul in his heart and allowed him to
become he obviously had extraordinary
talent to become that Rhett great writer
and in some ways I think literature
allowed him to transcend his
surroundings because Emily Dickinson
once said there is no frigate like a
book to take us lands away and through
literature he was able to go with
Shakespeare's Kings to England though he
never went there in his life he was able
to go to Spain and Portugal with Lord
Byron and that love of books was so much
a part of him that because it was
self-taught I think it got into his soul
in a way I compare that with the
education today it's so broad you know
our students take so many different
courses and fragments of one course and
another and maybe they don't get as deep
a feeling for the literature of a few
great things as they might and certainly
as Lincoln did in the old days plus the
fact that I mean he just wrote and
edited and wrote it was part of a muscle
in him that from the time he was a child
developed more and more and I think what
happens today is there's so many speech
writers on that White House staff not
just with Bush but previously and so
they're not doing it themselves in the
same way so they're not getting better
because it isn't part of their
importance but
it is important because communicating to
the country and being able to give them
a sense of where you're taking them
still remains a central tool for for a
president and television can't take away
from the words the words have to be
there the words to persuade I mean
Roosevelt would spend when he went on
his fireside chats I always thought he
was on the radio every week like our
current presidents are turned out he
only gave about 33 fireside chats in his
12 years as president only two or three
a year because he said he worked on them
so hard it would take a whole week out
of his presidency to make sure the words
were right
so that's what I think we need in our
modern day not just for our presidents
but for our young people the morning of
February 22nd 1958 it was a Saturday
morning you received a phone call early
in the day you get off the phone and
your father says my pal is gone right my
pal is gone what happened well my mother
had had this rheumatic fever as a child
and a weakened heart had had several
heart attacks when I was growing up but
somehow I still never thought that she
would die and she had died in her sleep
that night and you know when you're a
child I mean you're 15 years old I think
the hardest thing is just that you can't
imagine right away that it's happened so
my sister was there my and my this
wonderful middle sister who actually
came and stayed home with our family she
was a nurse in New York at the time so
that she could help take care of me and
in many ways became a second mother to
me but in a certain sense I think when
you're that age you don't even
appreciate the loss as fully as I did
later when I had my own children
I knew that my children would never know
my mother I never be able to share my
mother with them they never know their
grandmother as they never knew my father
either the older you get the more you
realize how devastating it is to lose a
parent at that age you're so wrapped up
at that time in your life that somehow
you think life you just force yourself
to have life go on and you're back in
high school you're back with your
friends and it's later I think more that
I realized what a vacuum had created in
my life but on a lighter note you talked
about how your sister was embarrassed
when your mom was pregnant with you oh
yes well you see I was a late child in
the family one sister was 15 and one was
10 when I was born and so they must have
thought what are these old parents doing
having this other kid come along so
thank God thank God my mother did get
pregnant
I was glad for that needless is that
Orem Utah you're next
yes my first question is why do you
believe there was such animosity between
Lyndon Johnson and Robert Kennedy was a
political differences or personalities
personal problems and the second have
you considered I loved yearbook
Fitzgerald's and Kennedy's have you
considered writing a book about
President Kennedy thank you well I think
the animosity between Lyndon Johnson and
Bobby Kennedy was partly personal and
partly political somehow those two men
just hated each other and I think that
was visceral you know you just come up
against somebody and you can't stand
them and I think it was then exacerbated
by the fact that when when Johnson was
made vice president he had been such a
powerful majority leader and he felt as
vice president that he was left out of
the loop on all sorts of decisions that
that Kennedy was making and he somehow
didn't want to blame Kennedy he liked
Kennedy in fact the two of them Jack
Kennedy and Lyndon Johnson got along
fairly well
Kennedy liked listening to Johnson's
stories he knew what a character in a
rogue Johnson was but then when he
wasn't getting invited to meetings or in
decisions he always blamed Bobby he
thought Bobby was keeping him out of the
meetings and then when Lyndon Johnson
becomes president after John Kennedy has
died I think Bobby felt that somehow
Johnson was upstaging his brother that
he had become such an important
president the civil rights things that
happened under his watch and that
therefore somehow his brothers echo and
history would be lessened and then of
course when Bobby runs for the Senate
and then it's potentially going to run
for the presidency against Lyndon
Johnson it only makes it worse so there
was absolutely no love left between
those two people I don't know you know
it's true my book on the Fitzgerald and
Kennedys ended with President Kennedy
becoming president and it didn't go any
further but they've been so many
wonderful books written about his
presidency that I'd have to be able to
figure out again a different way into it
if I were going to follow up with that
Palm Bay Florida you're next a great
honor miss Goodman I have three very
quick questions up is it can you name a
current senator that resembles a true
Democrat from the sixties and also was a
president Lincoln the is it true that he
was a
the father of the modern day income tax
and it was mostly for defense of our
country not really social social
programs and the last one is um do you
think Lincoln and Martin Luther King
would be proud of black Americans since
the civil rights of a movement ended
with the law and everything because it
seems to me like they they're really
squander and what there's they're still
fighting for civil rights that have
taken big opportunities that that have
been given to them thank well you know I
think the hardest thing for civil rights
leaders now is that after the fight for
segregation was won and after the Voting
Rights Act was was put into place to
argue about education and poverty it's
so much more scattered it's much harder
to have a focus for it and I think
that's part of the reason why we haven't
seen the same kind of dramatic sterling
leadership that we had in the 1960s but
I suspect that the times have just made
that much harder we haven't seen great
leaders anywhere I think for the last
few years so it's probably not fair to
blame the black leaders any more than
leaders in general you know when I think
about looking about who in that embodies
the values Democrats or Republicans the
most important thing that I think
Lincoln had was this extraordinary
empathy that was able to see both sides
of an issue he gave a great speech when
he was a young man to a temperance
society in which he argued you're never
going to change people who are drinking
or the DRAM sellers who sell the drink
by denouncing them by using anathema an
anthem of Reason a themá-- denunciation
beats denunciation and he called for
trying to understand he said the best
way into a person's heart is to
understand them and not to simply shun
them men will retreat within themselves
so I think what we need is not somebody
who's simply an activist Democrat or an
activist Republican but somebody who can
understand where both sides are coming
from and the problem now is that our
system makes that so much less likely
the primaries reward people with the
most extreme positions on either side
television loves people who are point
counterpoint who can really say you know
exactly what they feel and then the
other person on the other side I mean I
look at people like John McCain and I
think he's one of the people who's
trying to understand where the Democrats
are even though he's a Republican we
need Democrats who can understand where
the Republicans are because
we're never going to get anywhere with
this kind of denunciation breeds
denunciation which is where our politics
is at today Lincoln would be very sad
about that I think good afternoon to
Salem Oregon you're next yes Doris I had
the great pleasure of listening to you
speak at Willamette universal experience
my question is about Mary Lincoln and
how she was treated by those colleagues
and supporters of Lincoln after he was
assassinated and also if you came across
in your research any information about
an abram Wigman who's an ancestor of
mine who reportedly was a close friend
of Mary Lincoln thank you very much yes
definitely there is an abram Wakeman and
he was in New Yorker and he supported
Mary a little bit after he died after
Lincoln died helping her she was always
worried about whether she had enough
money to exist and she wrote lots of
friendly letters to Abram Wakeman you
should look for them in the Lincoln
collection because or in the Mary
collection because I think you'll find
your ancestor an interesting character
the sad thing I think for Mary was that
even once she became first lady there
was no place for her to find a footing
the southerners distrusted her of course
because she was married to Abraham
Lincoln the northerners distrusted her
because she had four Confederate
brothers stepbrothers in the Confederate
Army Westerners and Easterners rather
thought that she was kind of crude
because she was a westerner so she tried
to redecorate the White House and make
it a symbol of the Union as the one
contribution to his presidency but at
the time when the soldiers didn't have
enough money for blankets as Lincoln
later said it seemed like the wrong
thing to be spending money on these love
dogs as he put it in the White House so
her reputation during his presidency was
really hurt a lot and when he died there
wasn't the same wellspring of support to
help her I mean it seemed unfair in a
way I mean they gave they gave grant a
house you know they were providing
pensions for other people and they
didn't for a long period they finally
had to fight to give Mary any kind of a
pension and I think it was in part
because she had had such bad press
during his presidency and then she felt
that they owed it to her afterwards and
or also goes last year she was so
worried about money and and unwisely
spending it she may have had some manic
fitness there's one point at which she
bought 300 pair of gloves that her son
fearing that he needed to protect her
put her into an asylum she actually was
able to get out pretty soon proving that
she was not mentally ill but then went
to live in Springfield and had a very
sad ending to what should have been a
much happier life there was a ball that
took place shortly before Willie passed
away why did the Lincoln host this ball
and why was that significant in your
book well what happened is Mary was
trying to figure out a new social
function that would be dramatic for the
White House most of the right house
receptions were open to anybody so they
would be rather crude affairs at the
exact Woodsman are coming in with a
diplomat side by side so she decided to
have an invitation-only ball and the
invitation became the hottest card in
Washington and it was a very exciting
event she planned it for weeks and week
right before the event her son's both of
them Willie and Ted got very sick and
she thought actually she should cancel
the ball but Lincoln decided that the
doctor had said they were recovering it
would be all right that the ball could
still be held so they held it but during
that night of the ball which should have
been her triumph in fact everybody said
it was a great innovation this ball she
kept going upstairs to see Willie and
Ted and then when Willie died not long
thereafter she felt in a certain sense
that it was her pride and her our desire
to do these things in the White House
that somehow it offended God and ended
up with Willie dying so that ball was
always a terrible memory even though
it's her moment of triumph as a First
Lady
Boston is next going please hello Doris
I'm very glad you here you you're a
wonderful speaker and I would like to
ask you two questions have ever thought
of recording some of the interesting
stories of history and because you're so
adept at describing them and the second
question I have is do you think the war
in Iraq is actually a skirmish in a
larger conflict between Islam and
Christianity which might eventually end
in the war well you know as far as
recording the stories there is a
wonderful thing I think about oral
history you know whether I'm a part of
it or not it's a great thing I think to
allow people's voices and they now are
doing it more and more with living
politicians and living people I mean
even during
world war 2 for example oral histories
were done of women who went to work in
the factories and the stories they told
are just you could never get them later
and they're in their own voices and then
those oral histories get transcribed so
I think the general idea of transcribing
stories is critical for history
I remember hearing those factory workers
talk the women would say when they came
home after when their husbands came home
after World War two and they suddenly
saw their wives who've been working
independently in factories writing a
check what are you doing you've never
written a check before you know they
said they somehow felt like they had
become oak trees when they were guarding
their husbands couldn't deal with it
when they got home or the funny stories
so many of the stories that make up the
sort of the the best part of history
occur between people saying them so I'm
very much in favor of oral histories
whether I do it or not and I think
there's no question but that as far as
your second idea goes that we are in
something large right now between not
just our country but between democracy
and Islam and we've got to just hope
that it doesn't become a larger war
because there's nothing more frightening
I think as there have been in history
when a war becomes a religious war and
there's some overtones of that where
there's no sense of any compromise
possible we could be in for a very long
and very bad time so we've just got a
hope that it doesn't escalate into
something like that there are elements
of it already but hopefully we can avoid
that our last question comes from your
first book and it's a viewer who was
honestly spend book TV bus recently from
Forrest and Illinois hi my name is Eric
Welch I was enforced in Illinois first
of all I want to say I'm a huge fan of
Brian lamb and c-span and book TV in
particular secondly thanks for the
opportunity to ask this question of
Doris Kearns Goodwin I wonder in the
research you've done on the many
presidents that you've examined whether
you've been able to identify any fatal
flaw in any of their presidencies I'm
particularly interested in that of
Lyndon Johnson I really enjoyed your
book Lyndon Johnson and the American
dream the fatal flaw and it probably is
not just confined to Lyndon Johnson when
things get tough for a president what
seems to happen is they hunker down with
the people who support their point of
view when the Vietnam War began to be
difficult when the country stops
supporting it as fully as they had
rather than reaching out for opponents
and rather than reaching out for those
congressmen and Senators who might have
given him a different perspective on
what to do in the war there was that
natural tendency to surround himself
with the people who agreed with him and
that only means that you fully yourself
even deeper into a whole and I think it
probably has relevance for us today you
know that when things are difficult the
time is then there to reach out to
people who disagree with you who can
debate with you who can argue with you
so that you can see other points of view
and maybe get out of the hole that one
is in what surprised you the most in
putting together a team of rivals well
you know I think the most superficial
thing that surprised me but it probably
isn't superficial is that having seen
the sad eyes that Lincoln had having
known about his melancholy temperament I
had no idea how dynamic a personality he
had I mean I'm sure the Lincoln scholars
who studied them their whole life
understood that but for me he ended up
being much more vital much more alive
I've even teased that he seemed even
sexy in one of the pictures there's this
great picture of him before that
terrible beard that he grew to please
this little girl and and there was a
sense in which he's got a rugged face I
think it's on page 200 he's got a rugged
face there's disheveled hair maybe I
liked his shovelled hair because my
husband's disheveled hair and big hair
like Lincoln's but but you look at that
and that's not the image we have when we
think of him in the marble monument and
then as I read further and I realized
that he was the one suspending
everyone's else's spirits that he could
start a cabinet meeting with a funny
story that he could relax people by
telling a joke and that these jokes were
so funny and amusing and they had
something to do with what was going on
there was a live force in him that I
hadn't suspected I knew I respected him
I knew I admired him but I didn't
realize I feel such affection for him
published by Simon & Schuster Doris
Kearns Goodwin the latest team of rivals
the political genius of Abraham Lincoln
by the way a complete list of all of her
works available at book tv.org
thank you Oh what great fun thank you
please come back again I'd love to
in depth with darkness Kearns Goodwin
re-airs tonight at midnight Eastern and
next Saturday at 9 a.m. Eastern